Thank you all for coming.
I'm going to begin by introducing a
Jordan,
Jordan Peterson,
and then I will,
um,
talk a little bit about how this event
is going to work and then we'll get
underway.
So Jordan Peterson has been called,
quote,
one of the most important thinkers to
emerge on the world stage for many years
by the spectator.
He has been a dishwasher gas jockey,
bartender,
Short Order Cook,
beekeeper oil,
derrick bit tipper plywood mill,
laborer and railway line worker.
He's taught mythology to lawyers,
doctors and businessmen,
consulted for the UN Secretary Generals
High Level Panel on sustainable
development,
help his clinical clients manage
depression,
obsessive compulsive disorder,
anxiety,
and schizophrenia.
Served as an advisor to senior partners
of major law firms,
identified thousands of promising
entrepreneurs on six different
continents and lectured extensively in
North America and Europe.
He has flown a hammerhead role in a
carbon fiber stunt plane,
piloted a mahogany racing sailboat
around Alcatraz Island,
explored in Arizona and media right,
creator with a group of astronauts,
built a native American longhouse on the
upper floor of his Toronto home and been
inducted into the coastal Pacific
Kwakwaka'Wakw tribe.
Malcolm gladwell discussed psychology
with them while researching his books.
Norman doidge is a good friend and
collaborator,
thriller writer,
Gregg Hurwitz employed several of his
quote,
valuable things as a plot feature in his
number one international bestseller,
orphan x,
and he worked with Jim Balsillie,
former R I,
m CEO on a project for the UN secretary
general with the students and
colleagues.
Dr Peterson has published more than 100
scientific papers transforming the
modern understanding of personality and
revolutionized the psychology of
religion with his now classic book maps
of meaning the architecture of belief as
a Harvard professor,
he was nominated for the prestigious
Levinson teaching prize and disregarded
by his current University of Toronto
students as one of three truly life
changing teachers.
Dr Peterson is a core of most viewed
writer and values and principles and
parenting and education.
He has innumerable twitter followers and
facebook followers.
His Youtube channel now has about a
million subscribers and his classroom
lectures on mythology were turned into a
popular 13 part TV series on TV Ontario.
Dr Peterson's online self help program.
The self authoring suite has been
featured in o the Oprah magazine on CBC
radio and on NPR is national website.
It has helped over 150,000 people
resolve the problems of their past and
radically improve their.
Without further ado,
please join me in welcoming Dr Jordan
Peterson to laugh.
Thank you.
So the way this is going to work is that
I'm going to have a conversation with Dr
Peterson for 90 minutes and then there
is going to be a 90 minute q and a.
This event is being video recorded and
will be published online for
noncommercial non advertising purposes.
Um,
during the q and a session when you were
handed a microphone,
please speak directly into it.
Our viewers on youtube will appreciate
it.
And finally,
I am a moderator between Professor
Peterson in the audience but also a
biased participant in this conversation.
Okay,
well,
it's a relief that's all over.
Okay.
So,
um,
I thought we would start things off with
this.
I assume that many in the audience are
curious but relatively unfamiliar with
you or have heard a lot about you
without ever reading or listening to
you.
So I thought we might start with you
introducing yourself to the audience and
maybe telling them some of the main
things that you think they might be
interested in knowing about you.
Well,
I guess the most relevant
detail is that I spent about
15 years writing this
and I worked on it about three hours a
day every day during that period of time
and um,
at,
at the same time I was finishing off my
doctorate and I started lecturing at
Harvard,
but I was doing that continually and
thinking about it continually and
reading the material that I needed to
read in order to write the book
continually as well.
And
I didn't realize until more recently
that what I was doing was at the heart
of the postmodern conundrum.
I would say
I was very much obsessed by the events
of the Cold War for reasons I don't
exactly understand.
I had a lot of dreams about nuclear
annihilation for years on end.
I mean,
it wasn't that uncommon to be obsessed
by that when I grew up.
I mean because it was a preoccupation of
everyone who was my age.
I suppose there,
there were lots of years,
probably between 1962,
I would say probably in 1985 where
people were pretty convinced that the
probability of a nuclear war was high,
much higher now than,
than,
than people considered now.
Um,
and I was curious about this.
I was about why everyone wasn't obsessed
about this all the time,
first of all,
because it seemed like the fundamental
issue that to armed camps were pointing
something in excess of 25,000 hydrogen
bombs each at each other.
I couldn't understand how anybody could
concentrate on anything other than that
since it seems so utterly insane.
Um,
and I was curious
what was going on exactly.
Yeah.
Was this,
one explanation was that there's a very
large number of ways that human beings
could organize themselves in society,
like a large number of games that we
could hypothetically play and they're
all equally arbitrary and then in an
equally arbitrary universe and that the
communists had decided to play one kind
of game and the West and the western
free market democratic types have had
decided to play another game.
And it was all arbitrary in some sense,
and so that's what I was trying to
figure out was what the hell was going
on with this conflict and was it merely
a battle between two hypothetically,
equally valid interpretations of the
world drawn from a set of extraordinary
large potential interpretations,
which I think would be essentially a
postmodernist take on it.
And I think I went into the problem
neutrally in that I didn't think I knew
what the answer was,
you know,
so lots of times when you talk to people
who think or when you talk to people who
write,
they have an idea and it's right,
and then they write whatever they're
writing to justify the idea.
That's how they look at it.
But it's not a good way to write.
A good way to write and think is to have
a problem and then try to solve it
right.
To actually solve it.
Not to demonstrate that you're a
priority.
Commitment is true.
And you know,
one of the signs I would say that my,
a priority commitments weren't.
The purpose for the writing was that I
walked away from that 15 year project
with a view of the world that was
completely different than the view that
I had going in and learned all sorts of
things,
especially about the role of narrative
and religious thinking in life that I
had no idea was possible when I started
and a lot of that was a consequence of
reading the great people who I read
deeply.
You know,
I read all,
all the great works of Friedrich
Nietzsche.
The great works of Dostoevsky and
Tolstoy and most of us collected works.
Everything that had been published up to
that point and a very large swath of the
relevant clinical literature.
The Great Clinicians of the 20th century
and a huge stack of neuroscience and et
Cetera,
et cetera.
Because I was reading constantly during
this time and
I realized some things that I think are
true.
The communists were wrong.
They weren't,
and not just a little bit wrong and not
wrong in some arbitrary way.
They were playing a game that human
beings cannot play without descending
into a murderous catastrophe,
and there's something about what we've
done in the west that's correct.
And I,
it's hard.
It's complicated because our,
our cognitive structures,
that's one way of thinking about it or
are socio political arrangements.
They're actually,
they actually parallel one another in an
important way,
aren't,
are grounded in a,
in a strange set of axioms.
The axioms aren't rational precisely.
It's more like their narrative,
their narrative axioms.
Uh,
their stories and the story of the West
is that the individual is sovereign over
the group and that that's the solution
to tribalism.
And I think that's the correct solution.
Now what that means metaphysically
because it's also embedded in our
religious doctrines,
right?
Because especially in Christianity,
although not exclusively to
Christianity,
the individual is sovereign,
the suffering individual is sovereign
and there's something about that that's
true at least psychologically.
And I don't know what that might mean
metaphysically because who the hell
knows what anything means
metaphysically,
right?
I mean,
your,
your knowledge runs out,
right?
At some point.
Anyways,
I worked all these ideas out and then I
taught for a long time courses that were
based on the ideas and the courses were
very impactful.
I would say they had the same impact on
the people that I was teaching as
walking through the material had on me
and while it was out of that that all of
this political
controversy arose.
I mean I was never focused on political
controversy even though I'm interested
in politics and I thought at many points
in my life about a political career,
I always put it aside for a
psychological and philosophical career I
would say and
but,
but things started to shift badly in
Canada over the last five years and our
government dared to implement
legislation that compelled speech and
one of the things that I had learned
when I was doing all this background
investigation was that there isn't a
higher value.
Then free speech isn't free speech.
It's not the right way of thinking about
it because it's free thought and even
that's not the right way of thinking
about it because thought is the
precursor to action in life.
So there's no difference between free
speech and free life and I was just not
willing to put up with restrictions on
my free life and so I made some videos
pointing out the pathology of this
doctrine and the fact that the
government had radically overreached
it's,
it's appropriate limits and well then
you know,
well,
and maybe you don't know,
but I've been involved in continual
scandal
since for 18 months as a consequence,
which to me as a clinician indicates
that I got my damn diagnosis.
Right,
right.
It's not about pronouns.
It's about something a lot deeper than
that.
And I stand by that.
I believe that it's the case and I don't
think that we would all be here tonight
if that wasn't the situation.
So.
So I wanted my first or my next question
to be about Lafayette.
And so I thought I would read a couple
of facebook posts that certain students
who are critical of you read in the lead
up to this event and just ask you to
respond to them.
So this is a student writing Lafayette
College.
I'm utterly disappointed that you're
allowing this to take place on our
campus.
I thought we went through this last
semester with roaming millennial,
inviting hateful speakers who make
wildly unsubstantiated.
Claims is not going to fly with the
student body.
I get it.
The middle series events are private and
not endorsed by the college that you
absolutely have the power to make a
statement on this,
the fact that you're not as an
embarrassment to our community.
If you believe that this man is a
legitimate source of knowledge because
he has a degree in clinical psychology,
feel free to ask our psychology
department faculty in Counseling Center
staff about the validity of his claims.
I'm certain they would not endorse this
speaker.
Do better in all caps.
For those of you unfamiliar,
Jordan Peterson is known for denouncing
the me too.
Movement,
claiming that women are in no way
marginalized in the west,
arguing against the existence of gender
neutral pronouns,
arguing against gun control in the US
and claiming that identity,
politics and social justice movements
are part of a devious Marxist agenda.
And then another student responded,
and this is briefer,
college conservatives know that if they
bring in a speaker who was willing to
blatantly insult a portion of the
audience and the libs get angry enough
about this for good reason,
then they may get an op ed written about
them in the New York Times.
As a result,
there are a whole group of hacks like
Milo and Peterson,
who get famous and invited purely for
their promise to Miss Gender,
trans students and advocate provocative,
but ultimately toothless arguments about
social darwinist race theory.
What I'm saying is that you have every
right to be pissed.
Jordan Peterson as a harmful moron,
but know that,
but know that you being pissed is also
100 percent at the point of why he was
invited.
He's not a conservative.
He's just a guy who's mildly racist
enough to offend the college liberals
and therefore secure winds for the
cultural right
comparatively mild stuff.
It's the chattering buzz
of ideologically possessed by demons,
so there's nothing in it that's not
entirely predictable.
That's.
That's one of the things you know,
you notice when you're talking to
people,
if you.
If you want to find out whether the
person is there or the ideology is
there,
you listen to see if you're hearing
anything that someone else have the same
ideological mindset.
Couldn't have told you.
You know,
like I've had thousands of conversations
with people because I've spent 20 years
as a clinical psychologist and one of
the things I've learned about people is
that there are unbelievably interesting.
If you get someone to sit down and you
move past the superficial,
which you can actually do quite rapidly.
They'll tell you all sorts of things
that only they know that are
unbelievably enlightening and about
their own peculiar problems about the
way they look at the world about their,
their idiosyncratic familial dynamics.
Like just fascinating personal stuff.
It's the stuff of great novels,
you know,
and just,
and this is ordinary people,
I don't really think there is an
ordinary person exactly there the facade
of ordinariness,
but behind that people are very rarely
ordinary.
And so their,
the conversations are almost
instantaneously fascinating.
And one of the.
One of the guidelines that I used in my
clinical practice constantly was like,
I had this sense,
I probably learned this mostly from Carl
Rogers,
was that if the conversation wasn't
really interesting,
then we weren't doing anything that was
therapeutically useful,
but the interesting,
all of the interesting elements of it
were were very,
very personal and so to replace this,
and I learned this mostly from so from
Alexander,
Solzhenitsyn in his detailed analysis of
what I would call ideological
possession.
He talked to.
He talked about people he met in the
Gulag camps who are under the sway of a
rigid communist Orthodoxy and noted very
clearly that it was like there was a
crank in some sense on the side of their
hand and you could just crank the crank
and out would come the ideological dogma
and it's all entirely predictable and
people who are in a situation like that
don't understand that they're possessed
by an idea.
Right?
It's Carl Jung said,
people don't have ideas.
Ideas have people and it's like so
there's nothing in that that's anything
other than exactly what you would
predict,
and then there's a deeper issue too,
and this is one that I think has
bedeviled me ever since I made my
initial videos,
which is
the route it's impossible for those on
the radical left to admit that anyone
who opposes what they're doing might be
reasonable because what that would mean
would be that you could be reasonable
and oppose the radical left and that
would imply that what the radical left
was doing wasn't reasonable.
And so instead of dealing with the fact
that I actually happened to be quite
reasonable,
the attempt is to assume that anyone who
objects must be part of the radical,
right.
It's like,
well actually no.
There's lots of space between the
radical left and the radical right.
There's the moderate reasonable left for
example,
and you.
And then there's the center and then
there's the moderate reasonable,
right?
And then there's the far right,
and then there's the extreme right.
All of that exists in opposition to the
radical left,
but it's very convenient for the
radicals on the left to say,
oh,
well you don't buy our doctrine,
and and,
and then to immediately make the
presupposition that you must be the most
highness example of that entire array of
potential objection.
It's like,
yeah,
well,
whatever,
you know,
it's just not a viable stance and so,
but it's convenient and it,
it,
it's a bad thing because it drives
polarization.
Now it's a bad thing,
but it also,
it doesn't address the issue.
So one of the things that I've been
thinking about deeply over the last
couple of weeks and plan to write about,
here's a mystery for all of you.
I don't care what your political
background isn't.
It isn't like I'm anti left.
I've made videos documenting this.
I know why there's a left wing.
There's a left wing because inequality
is a problem.
That's a way worse problem than the
radical leftists liked to admit because
you can't lay it at the feet of
capitalism and the free market
inequality is a way worse problem than
that,
but it's definitely a problem.
And because inequality is a problem,
you need part of the political structure
to speak up to the for the people who
end up a raid at the bottom of
hierarchies,
it's crucial.
Someone has to speak for them.
That's the place of the left.
But then,
but then consider this kit so we can
get.
We can state that the right speaks for
hierarchy and the left speaks on behalf
of those who are oppressed by
inequality.
Good.
We need that dialogue.
The radical left.
Okay.
We know from 20th century history that
things can go too far on the right.
No one disputes that and that things can
go too far on the left.
And we also know that when things go too
far,
it's seriously not good.
Right?
So when things went too far on the
right,
then we had 120 million people die in
the Second World War.
And when things went too far on the
left,
we had,
God only knows how many people murdered
as a consequence of internal repression.
At least $100,
million.
And we risk putting the entire planet.
We risk putting the planet into flames.
Okay,
so that's the consequence.
Alright,
so now in the aftermath of World War II,
let's say we've come to some sort of
sociological agreement.
I would say that you can identify the
radical right wingers.
When people make claims of racial
superiority,
you put them in a box and you say,
well,
you're outside of acceptable political
discourse,
and so you saw that with William William
f Buckley in the sixties when he started
his conservative review,
he disassociated himself from the David
Duke types and you saw it more recently
with people,
for example,
like Ben Shapiro,
who immediately distanced himself from
the Charlottesville types.
Okay,
so now we,
we kind of have a sense of where you've
crossed the damn line in your ethno
nationalism,
right?
As soon as you move into the racial
superiority domain,
ethnic superiority domain,
it's flight.
No,
you've got to be dangerous.
All right,
here's a question.
Where the hell do you across the line on
the left?
Exactly.
Well,
the answer is,
who knows?
Well,
that's not a very good answer.
I wouldn't say it's incumbent.
It's incumbent on people in the center
and in the moderate left to say,
look,
things can go too far on the left and
here's how we know that's happened and
that hasn't happened at all.
Now I think there's a reason for that.
I think there's a technical reason as
well as a motivational reason to
technical reasons.
It's harder for people on the left to
draw boundaries because people on the
left aren't boundary drawing types,
their boundary dissolving types,
temperamentally speaking,
so that's a problem.
The second problem is it doesn't look to
me like there is a smoking pistol on the
left.
That's as obvious as racial superiority
doctrines,
you know,
it's like they're in Canada.
There's a lot of push for this
triumvirate of of radical ideas,
diversity,
inclusivity and equity.
Which diversity.
It's like,
well,
who's against that?
It's like being against poverty.
Inclusivity.
Well,
yes,
of course we want people included
equity.
That's a more bitter pill to swallow
because that's equality of outcome and
for me that's a marker.
It's like if you're talking about
equality of outcome,
you've gone too far and if you're
talking about diversity,
inclusivity,
and equality of outcome equity,
then you've gone too far and you might
disagree.
You might disagree.
That's fine.
Disagree.
If that isn't the marker for going too
far,
then what's the marker?
Because obviously you can go too far and
obviously that's not good,
and to close on that,
I would also say to the people on the
moderate left,
if you want your doctrines to have
purchase and to continue to speak for
the,
for those who stack up at the bottom of
inevitable hierarchies,
then you owe it to yourself to
dissociate yourself from the dangerous
radicals because otherwise they
invalidate your ideas and that doesn't
seem to be.
You'd think the Democrats might've
learned that in the last election,
but they haven't.
They haven't learned that so
well.
So that's my spiel about those comments
I guess.
Okay,
so you've changed the lives of many
young people and adults in this country,
in the anglosphere,
in the west,
in the world,
you have a massive following.
My girlfriend's parents call you uncle
Jordan for example.
On the other hand,
and this is just a that tons of people
on the left as
we've just seen because of your power
and also your frontal attack on a lot of
their views,
hate you and viciously caricature you.
Then there are these other figures like
Jonathan Heit and Robbie George.
They have a lot in common with you.
They are respected academics.
They are at least relatively well known
outside academia.
They share your critiques of the
humanities of student activists,
have trends in western culture.
They don't have nearly the following
that you do,
but they also aren't as hated or
viciously caricatured.
Moreover,
they may have changed the minds of more
people on college campuses.
That is people on campuses who have some
sympathy for left activists or who may
agree with much of what you say,
but react negatively to confrontation
and harsh criticism.
Height has appealed the such individuals
by taking the Dale Carnegie Win friends
and influence people approach.
So my questions are first,
do you agree with this dichotomy?
Second,
did you consciously choose one path over
the other,
and if so,
why?
Well,
I mean with the height,
for example,
was more power to them as far as I'm
concerned.
You know,
he,
he has a different temperament than me.
He's,
he's more introverted,
he's less volatile,
I would say he's probably more agreeable
or more polite anyways.
Um,
and I think that what he's doing is
extremely effective,
especially from the perspective of very
carefully documenting the empirical
facts about the,
the ideological,
ideological,
the increasingly left-leaning
ideological tilt of campuses,
which is something that needs to be
explored on empirical grounds.
So,
um,
so like I said,
more power to him and there's nothing
wrong with being reasonable guess.
And then you asked,
well,
is that the right pathway for me?
It's like,
well,
apparently not a.
What happened when I made my initial
videos was that know I had,
I had spoke,
I talked to people a lot.
I,
I've worked with people a lot about
negotiation.
It's one of the things that I
specialized in,
I would say in my clinical and
consulting practice was teaching people
how to negotiate.
And I can tell you some things about
negotiating that you might find
interesting and useful.
The first is you can't negotiate from a
position of weakness.
So all of you who are going to be
developing your careers in the future,
you need to understand that if you want
to push your career forward,
well first of all,
that you do in fact have to push it
forward.
Because if you're competent and silent,
you will be ignored.
And,
and you know that's rough because you
might think,
well,
people should reward you because you're
competent,
and yes,
of course they should,
but if you're competent and silent,
then you're just not.
You're not a problem.
You're just part of the.
That's keeping
everything functioning.
And so if you want to develop your
career in terms of promotions,
say and salary is like you have to be
competent and you have to be strategic
and to be strategic,
when you negotiate for a new position or
for a new salary,
you have to be able to say,
if you don't give me what I want,
then something you don't like will
happen to you.
And what that means.
It's not a physical threat,
it's,
it's that you have an option,
you know,
so you have your CV,
your resume in order,
right?
You're educated and competent and
desirable to people outside of your
immediate job.
You're willing to instantly put yourself
in the job market and undergo the stress
of finding a new position and undergoing
interviews and all of that,
and you have that all planned out so
that when you go talk to the person that
you're negotiating with,
with regards to your salary,
you're credible and they see because
they.
It's very seldom that you're talking to
the person who's at the top of the
pecking order.
Let's say.
What you need to do that with them is to
tell them a story that they can tell to
their boss to make you not a problem.
And one a good story is,
look,
we really need this person because
they're hyper competent and they have a
better offer.
It's like,
well,
then you're going to win the
negotiation,
but if you go in there with no power,
well you're gonna lose obviously.
So the first thing that you need to know
if you're going to negotiate is that you
have to be able to say no and what no
means is that you're not going to do it.
And when I made the videos about bill
[inaudible],
I thought it through and I thought,
there's no damn way I'm following this
law.
I don't care what happens.
And I didn't say that lightly.
I thought it through.
I thought,
okay,
well let's assume the worst case
scenario.
And the worst case scenario would be
that a student would report me to the
Ontario Human Rights Commission and then
they would do an investigation.
Then they would find me guilty because
the Ontario Human Rights Commission
finds 99 percent of the people brought
to it guilty because that's what
totalitarians do.
And then I would refuse to pay the finer
cooperate with whatever the reeducation
they would put me through would be.
And then that would move to civil court.
And then I would be fine for contempt
and then it would,
you know,
then the whole legal catastrophe would
unfold.
And I thought,
well,
I could either do that or I could allow
the government to regulate my speech.
It's like,
nope,
that's not happening.
So you might think about that as
confrontational and it is confrontation.
Let's like there isn't a goddamn thing
that can be done to me to make me allow
the government to compel my speech.
That's not happening.
And the reason for that,
I believe the reason for that is because
I spent decades studying
totalitarianism.
It's not good.
And the way that totalitarian states
develop is that people give up their
right to be there,
right,
to,
to exist their own thoughts.
They lie,
they,
that's what happens is that individuals,
the individuals sacrifice their own
souls to the dictates of the state.
And then everything goes badly sideways.
So like,
and you think,
well,
how much evidence for that do we need,
you know,
you're looking at a quarter of a billion
deaths.
It's like,
isn't that enough?
Well,
the people that I read who were
profound,
Victor Frankel's a good example for
beginners,
if you want to read about this sort of
thing,
wrote a book called man's search for
meaning.
And Frankel and also Solzhenitsyn and a
variety of other commentators as well
who really looked into what happened in,
in,
in both the Nazi Germany and in the,
in the communist states.
Their conclusion was universal,
is that the lies of the state,
the lies and tyranny of the state are
aided and abetted by the moral sacrifice
of the individual.
It's not talked down.
The Nazis are telling you what to do and
you're all innocent.
Tendo Bank.
That's not how it works is you,
you falsify your,
your being bit by bit and you end up
where you don't want to be.
And that's a bad idea.
And if you're interested in that,
there's a great book by called ordinary
men and you read that and you won't be
the same person afterwards.
So I would be aware of reading it,
but it's a story about these policemen
in Germany.
So they were middle aged guys,
you know,
and they'd,
they'd been,
they grew up and were socialized before
the Nazis came to power.
So they are just your typical
middleclass policemen.
And they were brought into Poland after
the Nazis had marched through.
And um,
and charged with keeping order in the,
in the occupied state,
and they knew their,
their,
their commander knew that it was going
to be brutal because they were in war,
a war time and they regard the Jews for
example,
as enemies.
And so there was going to be a fair bit
of rounding up with all of that with all
of what that implied.
The commander told the policeman that
they could go home if they wanted to,
that they didn't have to participate in
this.
And then what ordinary men does is
document document their transformation
from ordinary policemen,
the sort of people that,
you know,
two guys who were taking naked pregnant
women out into the middle of fields and
shooting them in the back of the hat and
the documents one step at a time.
How an ordinary person turns into
someone like that.
You think,
well,
we don't want that sort of thing to
happen anymore.
Well then you don't want to be that sort
of person.
That's how it's fixed.
And if you're not going to be that sort
of person,
then you don't take the first steps
because the first steps lead you down a
pathway that at least in principle you
don't want to go so well.
I think part of what makes me combative
say,
compared to someone like height,
is that I've spent years looking at the
worst things there
are to look at and I've learned from
that and I've learned,
certainly learned things that I won't
do.
And one of them is I won't let the
government regulate my speech.
It's a mistake.
I don't care what compassionate
principles hypothetically motivate that
move.
It was unprecedented in English common
law that move.
And it was all buried under this leftist
compassion,
which is mostly,
it's mostly a lie.
So I have reasons I think other than
those that motivate someone like
Jonathan Height to be particularly
passionate about this issue.
So
on the subject of totalitarianism,
um,
I wanted to do something very quickly.
So
I'm guessing that even though most
people in the room have negative views
of both men,
they have a more intensely negative view
of Hitler then of Stalin.
I'm guessing almost everyone in the room
has a far more negative visceral
reaction to the swastika than to the
hammer and sickle.
Some of the protesters at your event at
mcmaster university stood behind a
banner with a hammer and sickle.
You've said that a hammer and sickle is
no funnier than a swastika.
That quote,
the reprehensive,
the reprehensible ideologies that are
based in fundamental Marxism killed at
least 100 million people in the 20th
century,
unquote.
I've discussed this proposition with
numerous people in recent months and
almost no one seems to buy it.
No one disputes the body count under
socialist regimes.
Few dispute that Stalin was a vicious
murderer roughly on par with Hitler in
moral terms.
Most think that communism should not be
tried again.
In other words,
they share your critique of the argument
that previous communist experiments did
not represent proper communism and that
proper communism should be tried.
Nevertheless,
they still disagree with you that we
should react as negatively to the hammer
and sickle as we do to the swastika.
Why?
Because they say the two ideologies are
not morally comparable.
National Socialism is much worse morally
than Marxism or Marxism.
Leninism.
So what do you say to this?
Well,
I would say the first thing is that it's
highly probable that you were talking to
intellectuals.
Students
will call them buddy intellectual.
It is a mystery,
you know,
it's uh,
it's a,
it is a mystery because it is the case
that there is something about the Nazi
doctor and that seems to have a visceral
impact that,
that the Communists doc,
Dr doesn't have.
And I said when I opened my remarks
tonight that it might be
the
issue of racial superiority.
You know,
it's,
uh,
it's something single that you can put
your finger on.
Whereas what's happening on the left
that's horrifying is murky.
It might even be multidimensional,
like maybe there isn't a single radical
leftist idea that's murderous,
like the racial superiority doctrine.
Maybe it's a combination of three or
maybe it's some set of four out of 10
who knows.
So,
and because of that,
it doesn't seem as repugnant.
And there was also a universalizing
tendency among the communists that
seemed to be less morally reprehensible
than the ethno nationalism of the Nazis.
So you know,
you think if you go back to 1914,
it's complicated.
But if you go back to say 19,
18 at the time of the Russian
revolution,
it's not like the communists knew that
their attempts to bring about the
socialist utopia would be due to
absolute murderous catastrophe,
right?
They were.
They were working in ignorance.
Now it's not that simple because by that
time,
Dostoevsky had already written the
devils,
the possessed,
and he outlined very,
very clearly what he thought would
happen if people like that got the reins
of power and Nisha had done the same
thing in his writing.
So people knew that there was something
toxic,
let's say,
and deadly about the doctrine,
but it hadn't been played out on the
world stage.
But now it's like,
well,
this is why I said what I said at the
beginning,
fine,
you know,
if,
okay,
I don't know exactly how to make the
moral distinction,
but it's a distinction that has to be
made.
I think that people who apologize,
who say something like,
I think,
I think that,
that it's virtually,
I don't know if it's as reprehensible to
say that a given ethnic group should be
consigned to the fire and to say that
wasn't real communism,
but they're damn close.
And when I hear someone say that wasn't
real communism,
I know what they mean.
What they mean was if I was the dictator
installing shoes,
I personally would have brought in the
utopia.
That's what that statement means.
And,
or it means,
uh,
an ignorance of history that's so
utterly appalling that,
huh?
That any political statement made on
behalf of that person whatsoever should
immediately be followed by a system.
Extreme embarrassment.
I say one just,
um,
I just want to be clear that these
students were conceding that they don't
agree that they share your critique of
it.
They don't share it enough.
Okay.
Fair enough.
I just wanted to make that clear.
But so,
so they would more or less agree with
what you just said.
I think about,
um,
it's not okay to say those regimes
weren't proper communism and the proper
communism should be tried.
They still dispute though that socialism
as an ideology is on par with Nazi-ism.
So I just wanted to make that we can say
communism.
Let's say we could say radical leftist
ideology,
as I said already.
There are reasons for the left and the
right wing,
right?
The right wing stands for hierarchy and
the left wing stands for the,
for those who are displaced by
hierarchy,
right?
An endless problem,
but that doesn't mean that still leaves
it in the camp of the people speaking on
behalf of egalitarianism to figure out
just what the hell went wrong and to
take some responsibility for it.
You know,
it's no joke and we see these things
play out continually.
Still look at what happened to
Venezuela.
Here's a fun story.
Do you know that it is now illegal for
physicians to list list starvation as
the cause of death for a Venezuelan
child in a hospital?
That's how they're dealing with the fact
of starvation right here.
Just make an illegal to have that
diagnosed as your cause of death.
That'll solve the problem.
So like,
you know,
we have a group of,
of well meaning socialists in Canada who
just produced something called the leap
manifesto a couple of years ago and it's
a pretty radical,
uh,
it's a pretty radical document.
They're trying to move our socialist
party,
the NDP New Democratic Party towards the
acceptance of this leap manifesto,
which doesn't look like it's going to
happen,
but they were all radical promoters of,
of the Venezuelan government before
everything went like badly sideways.
You know,
I think the average Venezuelan now has
lost 17 pounds.
Now.
It's not because they were put on a
voluntary dieting program.
Right?
It's not good.
And so if you're tilting towards the
left and you're temperamentally inclined
that way,
and half the population is,
then you have an ethical problem on
your,
on your hands,
which is how do you segregate yourself
from the radical policies that produced
the catastrophes of the 20th century.
And you can't just say,
well,
that's not my problem.
It's like,
well,
okay,
if it's not your problem now,
it certainly might become your problem
in the future.
So when I would say it's actually
everybody's problem in the aftermath of
the 20th century.
It's everybody's problem.
So,
so it's,
it's,
it's complicated.
Like there is a genuine desire,
like I worked for a Socialist Party for
quite a while when I was a kid,
you know,
and I saw both sides of it.
I saw some very,
very admirable people I was privy for
for a variety of chance reasons to the
leadership of the Socialist Party in
Canada at the provincial and the
national level.
I met the people who ran the provinces,
some of the provinces and who ran the
party and a lot of them were really
admirable people.
Like they'd spent their whole life,
I would say working on behalf of the
working class,
you know,
so they were genuine labor leaders and,
and,
and there was also a lot done in Canada
on the left that looks like it was
actually pretty good standard workweek.
The Info,
you know,
that the establishment of,
of pensions,
the introduction of our healthcare
system,
which I would say probably overall works
better than the American system,
although not at the upper end,
um,
and they were working hard on behalf of
people who had working class lives.
But then I also encountered the sort of
low level activist types and I didn't
have any respect for them at all.
I just thought they were peevish and
resentful and irritable.
And those two things exist in a very
uneasy coalition on the west.
There's care for the poor and hatred for
the successful.
And those two things aren't the same at
all.
And it looks to me like one of the
things that really happened when the
communist doctrines were brought into
play.
And also by the way we did the
multinational experiment,
right?
It doesn't matter where you put these
policies into play,
the same bloody outcome occurred.
Didn't matter whether it was Russia or
China or Cambodia or Vietnam,
or to pick a random African country or
Cuba or Venezuela for that matter.
It was an unmitigated catastrophe.
And so to me that's experiment plus
replication.
Not Enough,
well,
that has to be dealt with and it's not.
And the law,
the intellectual left in the West has
been absolutely appalling in their PSA.
Silence on the communist catastrophe.
Like for my students,
a lot of my students really haven't
heard about anything that happened in
the Soviet Union in any detail until
they take my personality class in the
second year of university.
It's like,
well,
what the hell?
Why are they learning about that in a
personality class in the second year of
university?
That's not.
That should be first and foremost in,
in their,
in their historical knowledge.
What happened in the 20th century.
I mean it was almost fatal what
happened?
And we still haven't completely
recovered from it,
right?
I think,
isn't your President Donald trump going
to talk to like insane totalitarian
number one sometime here in the near
future,
but that's still a Soviet era state.
Those people are armed to the teeth,
you know,
they have the weapon that they have
weaponry that could easily take you out.
And so we're not.
I don't know if you know,
do you know what happens if you blast a
single hydrogen bomb a hundred miles
above the United States?
Just one.
You lose all your electronics,
right?
They're all done.
Tractors,
cars,
trains,
subways,
computers,
phones,
all them burn out and that's it.
So we're not done with this yet.
And,
and the Korean state,
North Korea as an emblematic
representative of the communist
catastrophe and everyone there is,
starves.
There's millions of people died 20 years
ago.
It's not got any better.
So it's not like.
It's not like we solve this problem and
there's a deafening silence on the
intellectual side of the spectrum with
regards to what happened on the
egalitarian left.
And there's no excuse for it.
So,
so somewhat relatedly,
I think it's fair to say that even
though you have criticized segments of
both the left social justice warriors
and the right,
the alt right,
your critical commentary over the last
year and a half has focused
significantly more on the left than on
the right.
A lot of people I've talked to here at
Lafayette at Lafayette take issue with
that.
They say that we're so far from a
Marxist takeover of our culture and
political institutions that to suggest
otherwise is to engage in a classic kind
of right wing exaggeration and hysteria
that we've seen before in western
countries in the early to mid 20th
century.
They also say,
and this is important to them,
that the nationalist authoritarian right
poses more of a threat to freedom of the
individual than the left does today,
as it has in the West since the early
20th century.
They argued that the left may have sway
in the academy and large segments of the
media.
That nationalist right parties,
figures and movements with authoritarian
tendencies have risen,
become potent,
and often been victorious in recent
years,
and they point to trump brexit,
the national front pointing to trump.
Trump
is rather pointless.
I mean,
I don't know what trump is,
but to think of him as a figure of the
radical right is a little on the absurd
side.
So I mean we are polarizing and so who,
God only knows where the ultimate danger
will come from.
If it's the ethno nationalists on the
right or if it's the radical leftist,
so on the left,
who knows?
Right.
I,
I suspect to some degree that's a matter
of happenstance.
I mean that's what you'd expect if you
looked at 20th century history,
but I emerged out of the academy and the
academy,
like there are right wing people in the
academy not to speak of.
That's completely,
that's thoroughly documented and
certainly not the case in a country like
Canada.
There's no threat whatsoever in Canada
from,
from the radical.
Right.
It's like,
I don't know if you rounded up everybody
who was on the radical right in Canada,
you might be able to scrape up like what
three or 4,000 people if you really
like,
if you really worked at it,
you know,
so I just don't see that.
At least in my own country,
that's just a non issue.
It's a nonstarter.
I mean the last time there was any
kind of radical right wingers in Canada
was probably in Quebec in the 19 fifties
and maybe from the 19 thirties to the 19
fifties,
but it's never been a political issue.
What about the ASD or the Italian?
I can't remember the name of the Italian
party.
The National Front in France.
Where would you put would you.
Oh,
well,
I mean you're in Europe.
It's more,
there's more polarization I would say,
but the Europeans also have problems
that we don't have.
You know,
they've been,
they've been struggling with the
consequences of non ending violence in
the Middle East and the wave of refugees
that has emerged as a consequence of
that.
And so the situation in Europe is
different than I would say there is more
movement and activity on the right,
so,
but,
and you know,
I'm not a admirer of identity politics
while,
and that's for the reasons I brought up
to begin with think that you have to
decide
conceptually,
psychologically,
familiarly and socially what your vision
of a human being is.
And if your vision of a human being is
essentially tribal so that you're
defined by your collective identity in
some manner,
then you're going to play identity
politics on the left.
You're going to play identity politics
on the right.
It's like,
well,
I think the identity politics types on
the left pose a bigger threat in my
country.
It's not so obvious in your country
because you guys,
your political landscape is more
balanced,
I would say,
than ours.
If the radical right posed a threat to
the academy,
which they most decidedly do not,
then I would be just as upset about
that.
And so I think again,
it's,
it's part and parcel of the radical left
failure to take or the lefts in general,
failure to take responsibility for the
radicals.
It's like,
oh,
well,
why aren't you criticizing equally on
both sides?
Well,
the threat doesn't exist equally on both
sides,
not in my country.
So
I think identity politics is murderous
game,
no matter who plays it,
you know,
and on the left it's,
well,
we've already talked about that.
So what's wrong on the right while you
stand up and wave your flag and talk
about your ethnic identity or your
racial identity and you take pride in
that.
It's like,
what the hell did that have to do with
you yet had goddamn loser?
You know,
it's like you're,
you're one of the great heroes of the
past,
are you.
That's why you're standing up and waving
your flag.
It's no,
you're not.
You're,
you're identifying with your group
because you don't have anything of your
own to offer.
And so it's pathetic.
And I've said that many times and in my
lectures to,
and people know this,
if they've actually watched my
university lectures,
I spend a tremendous amount of time and
have for 30 years convincing my students
that if they had been in Nazi Germany,
there was a very high probability that
rather than being Oskar Schindler and
rescuing the Jews,
they would have been a Nazi persecutor
because there's like five Oskar
Schindler's and like many million Nazis.
So you can do the math for yourself and
if you don't think that,
if you think that you would have been
one of the few heroes,
then you're either someone truly
remarkable or you're unbelievably
diluted.
And so I would suspect that you're in
the unbelievably diluted camp because
truly remarkable people are rare.
And I've really.
I've really seen this in the last year
or two because one of the things I have
noted,
like I knew that people were timid,
you know,
and I knew why it's dangerous to stick
your head up above the rest.
I mean its Predator avoidance strategy
to keep your head down and I mean that
technically it truly is to blend in with
the crowd is a predatory avoidance
strategy.
That's what fish do in schools of fish.
Like it's very low level behavior and if
you stick your head up there's some real
danger and the advantage to that is that
people are pretty civilized and they go
along with the group and that's,
that's a good thing because you know,
we should be civilized and go along with
the group,
but it's a really bad thing when the
group goes sideways and I've had many
people,
colleagues but many other people to say,
wow,
we agree with what you're doing,
but we can't really take the risk of
standing up and saying.
So it's like,
well now and then so most people fall
into that camp.
When I went to Queens University a month
ago and was subject to that chilling
demonstration,
I would say were the radicals climbed up
into the stain glass window window wells
and pounded,
you know,
unendingly for 90 minutes while we were
all inside.
I had a professor write me the day
before and say,
look,
my wife and I work at the university,
we really support what you're doing,
but we can't even risk coming to the
talk because what if the students see
and complaint?
It's like,
well,
yeah,
there's courage for you,
man.
There's courage for it,
you know?
And so,
but that's par for the course and it's,
it's unsurprising to some degree.
Right.
Well,
but anyways,
on the right,
it's like
it's an excuse by people on the left not
to take the things that I'm saying.
Seriously.
That's what it is.
It's like,
wow,
he's not attacking the right as,
as,
as much.
It's like,
well,
they're not after me.
They're not trying to close down my
speech.
So I took that personally.
So had it been right wingers coming
after me.
Well,
it would've been the same thing.
So it's a foolish objection,
I think.
Okay.
For decades,
ethnic groups have,
on average,
scored significantly differently on Iq
tests.
According to psychology professor
Richard Hair,
whom you interviewed on your channel
Youtube,
there was no scientific consensus on the
causes of these average differences in
Iq test scores.
Yet,
according to Haier,
psychologists do generally agree that
general intelligence exists that Iq
measures that well and in a non
culturally
biased way that Iq is highly predictive
of success and educational and
professional terms and that for decades
ethnic groups have on average,
scored significantly differently.
So assuming this is true,
should we talk about it?
Sam Harris raised this question and a
podcast conversation with Charles
Murray.
Some argue that we should not talk about
this as doing so could fuel the racial
supremacist movements that you mentioned
with potentially horrific consequences.
Others mainly on the intellectual
darkweb and to a very limited extent in
academia.
Think we should talk about this topic
because average differences in Iq scores
have existed for decades.
They may have played a role in
generating the disparate educational and
professional outcomes that we observe
and care about.
And thus we cannot properly analyze
these disparate outcomes unless we do
talk about the subject openly.
Geneticists,
David Reich recently argued in the New
York Times that have scientists do not
openly discussed the biological basis of
race.
Pseudo scientists could fill the vacuum
with dangerous consequences.
Furthermore,
you,
Professor Peterson are highly critical
of the oppression narrative that
permeates segments of the academy and
activist left and knowledge about
average differences in Iq scores between
ethnic groups,
while tough to assimilate could puncture
this narrative.
So the question is,
what is your view on all that?
I've just said she's a.
You guys already didn't take a long time
to prepare these questions,
didn't you?
Alright.
So
when I went to Harvard,
I came from mcgill and I had spent a lot
of time with my advisor there and a
research team that he had trying to
understand the genesis of antisocial
behavior and
among adolescents mostly so well as kids
as well.
Anti social behavior is very persistent.
So if you have a child whose conduct
disordered at the age of four,
the probability that they will be
criminal at the age of 15 or 20 is
extremely high.
It's unbelievably stable.
It's a very dismal literature because
you see these early onset aggressive
kids and and it's persistent and then
you look at the intervention literature
and you throw up your hands because no
interventions work and believe me,
psychologists have tried everything you
could possibly imagine and a bunch of
things that you can't in order to
ameliorate that.
So we're really interested in trying to
understand,
for example,
if you're antisocial by the age of four,
then there isn't an intervention that
seems to be effective.
So,
and the standard penal logical theory is
really quite horrifying in this regard
because what you see is that male
aggression around the age of 15 and then
it declines fairly precipitously and,
and,
and sort of normalizes again by the age
of 27.
And Standard penal logical theory
essentially is this cold hearted.
It's like if you have a mold,
if you have someone who's a multiple
offender,
you just throw them in prison until
they're 27 and then the age out of it
and that's all there is to it.
That's,
that's what we've got.
Now there's some downside to that
because there's a corollary literature
that suggests that the worst thing that
you can do with antisocial people is to
group them together,
which is what we do in prisons.
So,
so that's a whole mess.
Anyways.
One of the things we were doing was
trying to see if there might be
cognitive predictors of antisocial
behavior.
And so we use this battery of
neuropsychological tests that was put
together at the Montreal Neurological
Institute,
took about 11 hours to administer and
hypothetically assessed prefrontal
cortical function.
We computerize that,
reduced it to about 90 minutes.
And then I'm assessed antisocial
adolescents in,
in Montreal,
and found out that they did show
deficits in problem solving ability that
we were associated with,
uh,
with prefrontal ability.
Um,
when I got to Harvard,
I thought,
well,
that's interesting.
We could use the neuro psych battery to
predict negative behavior.
Perhaps we could use it to predict
positive behavior.
So I thought,
well,
what if we turned the neuro psych
battery and over and thought,
well,
can we predict grades,
for example,
because you know,
that's a decent thing to predict.
So we ran a study,
we ran a study that looked at Harvard
kids,
University of Toronto kids line workers
at a Milwaukee factory and managers and
executives at the same factory.
And what we found was that the average
score across these neuro psychological
tests,
they were kind of like games.
They were game like,
you know.
So in one,
in one test you had,
there were five lights in the middle of
the screen and a box was associated with
each light and you had to learn by trial
and error,
which box was associated with,
with each light.
That was one of the tests.
Um,
so we took people's average score across
the tests because they seem to clump
together into a single structure.
You can do,
you can find that out statistically.
If you take a bunch of tests,
you can find out how they clumped
together statistically by looking at
their patterns of correlations and you
might get multiple clumps,
which is what happens with personality
research where you get five or you might
get a singular clump,
which is what happens in cognitive
research.
And we got a single plump essentially.
And then we were trying to figure out if
at the same time I was reading the
literature on performance prediction and
there's an extensive literature on
performance prediction.
A lot of it generated by the armed
forces.
By the way,
I'm indicating that ICU is a very good
predictor of longterm life success.
And so here's the.
Here's the general rule.
If your job is simple,
which means you do the same thing
everyday than Iq predicts how fast learn
the job,
but not how well you you do it.
But if your job is complex,
which means that the demands change on
an ongoing basis,
then the best predictor of success is
general cognitive ability.
And uh,
and I learned that the general cognitive
ability tests clump together into a
single factor that's fluid intelligence.
Or or ICU,
and then we didn't know if the factor
that we had found was the same factor as
Iq and it and we still haven't really
figured out whether or not that was the
case because it kind of depends on how
you do the analysis,
but anyways,
I got deeply into the performance
prediction literature and I found out,
well,
if you want to predict people's
performance in life,
there's.
There's a couple of things you need to
know.
You need to know their general cognitive
ability.
If they're going to do a complex job,
you need to know their trait
conscientiousness.
Some of you might've heard that
rebranded as grit in a very corrupt act
by the way,
because it's a good predictor of
longterm life success.
Freedom from negative emotion.
Low neuroticism is another predictor,
but it's sorta third on the hierarchy
and then openness to experience which is
a personality trait,
is associated with expertise in creative
domains.
The evidence that now I should tell you
since it's such a complicated question,
I should tell you how to make an Iq test
because actually really easy and you
need to know this to actually understand
what I que it,
so imagine that you generated a a set of
10,000 questions.
Okay.
About anything.
It could be math problems.
They could be general knowledge,
they could be vocabulary,
that could be multiple choice and really
doesn't matter what they're about as
long as they require abstraction to
Seoul,
so they'd be formulated linguistically,
but mathematically would also apply.
And then you have those 10,000
questions.
Now you take a random set of 100 of
those questions and you've given them to
a thousand people and all you do is sum
up the answers right from.
So some people are going to get most of
them right and some of some of them are
going to get most of them wrong.
You just rank order the people in terms
of their score,
correct that for age and you have Iq.
That's all there is to it,
and what you'll find is that no matter
which random set of 100 questions you
take,
the people at the top of one random set
will be at the top of all the others and
and with very,
very,
very high consistency.
So one thing you need to know is that if
any social science claims whatsoever are
correct,
then the ICU claims are correct because
the ICU claims are more psychometrically
rigorous than any other phenomena
phenomenon that's been discovered by
social scientists.
Now,
the ICU literature is a dismal
literature.
No one likes it.
Here's why.
Here's an example.
So here's a little,
here's a fun little fact for you,
for Liberals and conservatives alike,
because conservatives think there's a
job for everyone.
If people just get off their asses and
get to work and liberals think,
well,
you can train anyone to do anything.
It's like,
no,
there isn't a job for everyone and no,
you can't train everyone to do
everything that's wrong.
And here's one of the consequences of
that.
So as I mentioned,
the Armed Forces has done a lot of work
on ICU when they started back in 19,
19,
and the reason they did that was
because,
well for obvious reasons,
say let's say there's a war and you want
to get qualified people into the officer
positions as rapidly as possible or
you'll lose.
So that's a reason.
Now,
the armed forces has experimented with
Iq tests since 19,
19 and in the last 20 years I'm a law
was passed as a consequence of that
analysis,
which was that it was illegal to induct
anyone into the armed forces who had an
Iq of less than 83.
Now the question is why?
And that answer was all of that effort
put in by the armed forces indicated
that if you had an Iq of 83 or less,
there wasn't anything that you could be
trained to do in the military that
wasn't positively counterproductive.
Now you got to think about that a,
because the military is chronically
desperate for people right there.
It's not like they're sort of like
people are lining up to be inducted,
right?
They have to go out and recruit and it's
not easy and so they're desperate to get
their hands on every body they can
possibly manage and then especially in
wartime,
but also in peace time,
but then there was another reason too,
which was the armed forces,
was also set up from a policy
perspective to take people in the
underclass,
let's say,
and train them and move them up at least
into the working class or maybe the
middle class.
So there's a policy element to it too.
And so even from that perspective,
you can see that the military is
desperate to bring people in,
but it all with an Iq of 83 or less,
it's not happening.
Okay,
so how many people have an Iq of 83 or
less?
Ten percent.
Now,
if that doesn't,
if that doesn't hurt you to hear,
then you didn't hear it properly.
Because what it implies is that in a
complex society like ours and one that's
becoming increasingly complex,
there isn't anything for 10 percent of
the population to do.
Alright,
well what are we going to do?
We're going to ignore that.
We're going to run away from that and
believe me,
we have every reason to,
or we're going to contend with the fact
that we need to figure out how it is,
how it is,
how it might be possible to find a place
for people on the lower end of the
general cognitive distribution to take
their productive and worthwhile place in
society.
And that isn't just going to be a matter
of dumping money down the hierarchy
because giving people who have nothing
to do money isn't helpful.
It doesn't work.
It's not that simple.
Well,
so that's kind of an answer to the
question of whether or not we should
deal with,
uh,
with Iq forthrightly.
It's like,
if you can find a flaw in that logic,
like just go right ahead.
It's not like I was thrilled to death to
discover all of this by nose,
by no stretch of the imagination.
Was that the case?
So,
so what?
So Iq is reliable and valid.
That's the first thing.
It's more reliable and valid than any
other psychometric test ever designed by
social scientists by a factor of about
three.
That's fact number one.
Fact number two is it predicts longterm
life outcome at about point three,
point four,
which leaves about 85 percent,
70 to 85 percent of the story
unexplained,
but it's still the best thing that we
have.
Well,
it's also the case that in places like
Great Britain,
when Iq tests were first introduced,
they were actually used by the
socialists and they were used to
identify poor people who had potential
cognitive potential and to move them
into higher Ed Institutes of higher
education.
So there's an upside social upside as
well.
Ethnic differences.
This is something you can't say anything
about without without immediately being
killed.
So I'm hesitant to broach the topic,
but I'll tell you one thing that I did
in the last week that's relevant to
this.
So the,
and this just shows you how complex the
problem is.
First of all,
we should point out that race is a very
difficult thing to define because racial
boundaries aren't tight,
right?
So and so when you talk about racial
differences in Iq,
you,
you're faced with a thorny problem of
defining race and now it's a big problem
from a scientific perspective.
But we'll leave that aside and I wrote
an article this week,
somebody stood up at one point,
one of my talks and vice bless their
hearts,
took this particular question and used
it as an indication of the quality of
the people who are my so called
followers.
And by the way,
the quality of my so called followers is
pretty damn high.
And you can find that out quite rapidly
just by going looking at the youtube
comments which are head and shoulders
above what the standard set of youtube
comments.
I can tell you that.
So someone asked me the both the Jewish
question,
right?
And the,
the implication it was actually someone
Jewish and the implication was that Jews
are overrepresented in positions of
authority and power and,
and I was,
had just spoken for like an hour and a
half and you know,
this guy had an ax to grind and I
thought there is no God damn way I'm
getting into this at the moment.
And so I,
I said I'm,
I said I can't answer that question,
but that's not a very good answer.
So I wrote a blog post this week and I
said,
look,
here's the,
here's the situation,
all right,
Jews are overrepresented in positions of
power and authority,
but then let's open our eyes a little
bit.
Hey and thank for like two or three
seconds and think,
hey,
guess what?
They're also overrepresented in
positions of competence and it's not
like we have more geniuses than we know
what to do with.
And if the Jews happened to be producing
more of them,
which they are,
by the way,
then that's a pretty good thing for the
rest of us.
So let's not confuse competence with
power and authority,
even though that's a favorite trick of
the radical leftists who always failed
to make that distinction.
Well,
why does this over representation occur?
Because it does it also.
There's also overrepresentation in
political movements,
including radical political movements.
Okay?
Why?
Well,
answer one Jewish conspiracy.
Okay.
That's not a very good answer.
We've had,
we've used that answer before.
Alright,
but,
but do we have an alternative?
Well,
here's an alternative.
The average Ashkenazi Iq is somewhere
between 1:10 and one slash 15,
which is about one standard deviation
above the population average.
And so what that means is that the
average Ashkenazi Slash European Jew has
an Iq that's higher than 85 percent of
the population that's a lot higher now.
That doesn't make that much difference
in the middle of the distribution.
Okay?
But geniuses don't exist at the middle
of the distribution.
They exist at the tails of the
distribution and you don't need much of
a move at the mean to produce walloping
differences at the tails.
And the tails are important because a
lot of where we draw,
we draw exceptional people from the
exceptions.
Right?
So here's an example.
Here's another example of the same
thing.
Most engineers are male.
Why?
Because men are more interested in
things and women are more interested in
people and you might say,
well that's sociocultural.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
And we know that because if you stack up
countries by their,
by their egalitarianism,
social policies,
which you can do quite effectively.
And then you look at the
overrepresentation of men in stem
fields,
the overrepresentation increases as the
countries become more egalitarian.
So it's not socio cultural,
okay,
now men aren't that much more interested
in things than women.
It's one standard deviation,
which is about the same difference by
the way,
between the population norm in the
Ashkenazi Jews.
But if you're looking at the person who
the one person in 20 or the one person
in 50 who's most who's hyper interested
in things and that's likely to become an
engineer,
then most of them are men.
Here's another example of the same
thing.
Men are more aggressive than women.
Now you might ask how much and now
answered.
That is best place to look at that as in
Sweden where the egalitarian policies
have been laid out for a long period of
time and you can.
You can get a more direct inference
about biology.
If you took a random man in around
random woman out of the population and
you had to bet on who was more
aggressive and you bet on the man you'd
be right 60 percent of the time.
So that's not that much,
right?
It's,
it's deviates from 50 slash 50,
but it's not like 90 10.
It's 60 slash 40.
Okay.
So,
so what does that mean?
Well,
we got a tail problem here.
Again,
let's say that now you decide to go out
onto the extremes of aggression and you
identify the most aggressive one in 100
persons.
They're all men.
Guess who's in prison?
Those people.
That's why most of the people in prison
are men.
And so this is elementary part of the
problem in our society is that we don't
understand statistics.
We don't understand that you can have
relatively small differences at the
population level that produce walloping
consequences at the tails of the
distribution.
Okay.
So back to ICU.
One final thing to say about Iq.
The ethnic differences are difficult to
dispense with.
It's not easy to make them go away.
You can say,
well the tests aren't culture fair.
Well here's the past of that.
So imagine you,
you task group a with an Iq test and you
test group B with an Iq test and then
you look at their actual performance in
whatever you're predicting.
If the test was biased against ethnic
group A,
then it would under predict their
performance and that doesn't happen.
Now you could say,
well,
there's systemic bias in the performance
measures and the potential measures and
that's a possibility.
All right.
Now one other thing about that.
There's a real danger in the ethnicity
Iq debate and the danger is that we
confuse intelligence with value or that
we include we we confuse intelligence
with yet with human value.
That's a better way of thinking about it
and one of the things that we're going
to have to understand here is that
that's a mistake,
is that being more intelligent doesn't
make you a better person.
That's not the case.
It makes you more useful for complex
cognitive operations,
but you can be pretty damn horrific as a
genius son of a bitch,
right?
It's morally neutral,
and we also know that from the
psychometric data.
By the way,
there doesn't seem to be any
relationship whatsoever between
intelligence and virtue,
and so if it does turn out that nature
and the fates do not align with our
egalitarianism presuppositions,
which is highly probable,
we shouldn't therefore make the mistake
of assuming that if group a or person a
is lower on one of these attributes than
group B or person b,
that that is somehow reflective of their
intrinsic value as human beings.
That's a big mistake.
No,
that's why I don't have anything else to
say about that.
Okay.
So,
um,
I had three more questions and so maybe
slightly shorter answers to these three,
like maybe around.
Hopefully there are simpler questions.
Average,
average five minutes.
Um,
and then.
And then we will open it up.
So another taboo is to celebrate
European culture.
Multiculturalists get pretty unhappy
when Europeans start expressing pride in
their culture or heritage.
Many,
especially on the left,
do not draw much of a distinction,
at least in practice between European
pride and white supremacy.
You care about freedom of the
individual,
the individual's freedom to think,
to speak,
to associate in short,
to act as he sees fit without external
compulsion,
as long as he doesn't infringe on the
similar liberties of others.
Professor Ricardo do shame.
A historical sociologists and professor
at the University of New Brunswick
argues that quote,
individualism is a unique attribute of
European peoples.
Quote,
it has been exported to some degree to
other nations,
but in my view,
it is not something that comes to them
naturally,
so he continues.
Quote,
you can't play the game of we're all
individuals.
We have to affirm and be proud of our
ethnic identity and heritage to preserve
the West's curious individualism.
If Europeans have become minorities in
the west,
he argues the founding idea of the West,
that no entity,
not an individual,
not a community,
not the state congested.
We deprive an individual of life,
liberty,
or property by force,
no matter what the individual's race,
class or religion.
I wouldn't be surprised if Dushane when
he made this statement,
had you in mind.
Look,
the
medieval Europeans identified seven
deadly sins for reason and one of them
was pride.
It's like,
let's make the presumption.
I do believe that for for reasons that
aren't obvious that the west has got
some things right.
We've got the sovereignty of the
individual,
right?
That's the most fundamental thing we've
got,
right?
We've articulated that I think in a,
in a remarkable way,
not only theologically,
philosophically in her body of laws and
our societies,
and one of the consequences of that as
it's had its effect on the rest of the
world is that everyone is getting richer
quite fast and that's a really good
thing.
Okay.
Having said that,
it's like,
am I proud of that?
It's like,
I didn't do that.
What the hell?
Pride.
What's that?
That's not the right response.
How about responsibility for that?
How would that be?
It's like you're a part of.
This is great
and unlikely set of propositions.
This strange set of propositions that
says that in some ineffable manner,
the poorest person is as valuable as the
king.
It's like,
how the hell did we ever figure that
out?
That's an impossible thing to think,
and yet that's the,
that's the bedrock of our legal system.
That's nothing to be proud of.
That's something to tremble before to
take on as an ethical burden and not to
wave a flag for how wonderful you are
that you happened to have the same skin
color as some of the people who thought
that up.
It's not the right response.
It's like it's,
it's to open your eyes and recognize
that as a miracle and a relatively,
uh,
relatively new miracle on the world
stage and to,
and to participate in the process of
upholding that in your personal and your
public life.
That's not pride in European tradition.
Like when I go to Europe and I love
going to Europe and the European cities
are there unbelievable masterpieces,
which is why they're completely flooded
by pilgrims,
right?
Tourists,
pilgrims who go there to look at the
beauty.
So again,
I don't feel pride about that.
I feel.
I feel like I have something to live up
to that's not the same thing man.
And so these right wingers in this,
it's like,
look what we've done.
It's like,
no,
it's not you that did that.
That's something mad you gotta.
You GotTa have your act together before
you would dare to say,
well,
that was me.
It's like,
yeah,
sure,
sure it was you.
Yeah,
right.
No,
it's hard to stand up and take your
place in that,
in that kind of historical process,
that unlikely,
miraculous historical process,
not to just feel ashamed at the way that
you're presently constituted in the face
of that means that you're.
You're diluted and you're using your,
your your great fortune of being a
beneficiary of that system.
Look at what we've got here,
this great pace that we're inhabiting
right now.
You're using your unearned,
the unearned gift that's been granted to
you as a source of personal pride in
your accomplishments do to your skin.
It's like,
no,
not good.
Not a good argument.
So,
and that doesn't mean that while there's
nothing valuable about European culture,
there's plenty.
There's plenty about it that's value.
It's not even so clear to what degree
it's European.
I mean,
it came out of the Middle East,
you know,
mean who it's so muddle headed that you
hardly know where to start,
so hopefully that was less than five
minutes.
There we go.
Dispensed with the radical right wingers
in four minutes.
I've heard a number of interesting
things about Islam from you and one of
your intellectual soul.
Nate's Camille Talia,
Talia says that men and women benefit in
many ways from living and largely
separate worlds as they did and
traditional European societies and
obviously as they do in much of the
Muslim world.
Relatedly,
Polya considers passionate masculinity a
critical force for defending,
sustaining and advancing civilization,
and she argues the passionate
masculinity while virtually moribund and
the western middle and upper classes is
alive and well in the Muslim world.
You have expressed some sympathy for the
Muslim critique of the West.
It's godlessness.
It's spiritual void.
It's materialism.
It's technology induced removal from
life's elemental realities.
You've said it is extraordinarily naive
to believe that the,
that the differences between European
culture and Islamic culture are not
about anything fundamental.
You've expressed concern that Islam is a
totalizing system,
and in a quote that stood out to me,
you said in a Patrion chat on youtube
that in your view quote,
the only countries in the world that are
essentially worth living in in any real
sense are the ones that are predicated
on the Judeo Christian tradition and
manifested in the western body of laws
unquote.
So an open ended question,
how would you synthesize your
perspective on Islam and the fact that
the Muslim populations of Europe and
Canada,
a product of recent immigration are
growing and reproducing much faster than
the European descended populations in
these countries?
Yeah,
and you guys already did spend a lot of
time coming up with troublesome
questions,
didn't you?
When we get,
we can see the problem is the problem.
One of the problems is is that I'm an
ignorant man and there's lots of things
that I don't know.
No one I don't know.
I don't understand Islam.
I don't know enough about it to be an
intelligent commentary on it.
I've done my best to peck away at the
edges,
but you know,
it would require multiple years of study
to understand the similarities and
differences between the two viewpoints.
It looks to me like what Islam did was
take a group of radically disparate
tribes and unite them under a single
ethos.
Of course,
the in the Muslim civilization expanded
more rapidly than any other civilization
ever had and and,
and,
and occupied a very large part of the
world,
which of course it still does.
Perhaps there's something to be said for
that unifying tendency.
There is a problem
and maybe this is at the core of the
problem.
There is no distinction between Church
and state in Islam
and there is a between church and state
in the West.
It isn't obvious to me if it's the case
that our culture is grounded in an
underlying,
let's call it literary metaphysics,
something like that.
A religious metaphysic.
Part of the bedrock of our culture is
the idea of the separation between
church and state and as far as I can
tell,
that idea doesn't exist in the Muslim
world and so I cannot understand how
that faith is commensurate with the
institution's of the West.
It doesn't seem to me that there's any
evidence that it's commensurate because
the number of Islamic democracies is,
let's call it finite.
The best example is probably been Turkey
and Turkey as far as I can tell,
isn't doing that well at the moment on
the Democratic Front and it looked like
the great shining hope and Lord that was
a consequence of secularization.
You know,
I've spent a lot of time when I was
reading maps of meaning for example,
looking for commonalities among
religious viewpoints and I was able to
find deep commonalities.
I thought between Buddhism and
Christianity and daoism and Christianity
and Hinduism and Christianity for that
matter was a lot harder when it came to
Islam.
It's not a faith that's opened itself up
to me.
I don't understand it well,
but I hope that people of goodwill
can build a bridge between the two
cultures because the alternative is to
glue me to contemplate,
and finally you've stated quote,
women are more agreeable by nature than
men and agreeable people are
compassionate toward those.
They see a suffering and that seems to
include any minority,
especially when you combine that with a
kind of neo Marxist doctrine that claims
that anyone who has an advantage swiped
it unquote.
Women have been voting for a century now
and this you suggested in a patrion chat
may help to explain why in the West,
we've collectively decided that quote,
egalitarianism and conflict avoidance
constitute the two highest virtues and
trump everything else,
including free speech unquote.
You've said that in the West today,
we are perhaps for the first time in
history seeing on the political left or
on segments of the political left quote,
what a female totalitarianism would look
like,
unquote
elaborate.
I did a research project with one of my
students.
We haven't published it unfortunately
for a variety of reasons.
She's been quite ill and I've been quite
preoccupied.
So those are the two barriers at the
moment,
but the first thing we wanted to do was
to find out whether there was actually
such a thing as political correctness.
You can actually do that technically as
a social scientist.
So what you do is,
this is what we did is we got a group of
people together and we collected a whole
bunch of statements that seem to be
vaguely associated with the idea of
political correctness.
So maybe you could think,
well it's a media construct and that's
fine.
You can go analyze media statements and
then you can collect ideas that seem to
be associated with whatever political
correctness is.
We collected about 400 of those and then
we asked,
we turned them into questions and we
asked a thousand people for their
opinions.
Then you can do this statistical process
called factor analysis and it's the same
thing that pulls out a single factor of
Iq from a group of questions.
For example,
it's the same thing that produced the
big five personality model.
What the factor analysis does is tell
you which quest if questions grouped
together.
So let's say you have an opinion,
a,
well,
if you have an opinion,
a,
if there's 100 of you,
everyone who has an opinion,
a also has an opinion be an opinion
seat.
And if that's the case,
then those clump together,
there's something about them that's the
same.
Now,
what we could have found was that when
we analyze these 400 questions,
there was like 50 clumps and so that
would have blown.
There's such a thing as political
correctness hypothesis out of the water,
but that isn't what happened.
We found two clumps,
one of which looked like something like
moderate left and the other that looked
very much like totalitarian political
correctness.
And it was very,
very robust finding.
And we replicated it as well.
She did this for her master's thesis by
the way.
Um,
and then we looked at what predicted
these beliefs.
First of all,
that the correlation between the
moderate leftist clump of questions and
the radical leftist clump of questions
actually wasn't very high.
And so one of the things that we surmise
is that there's an actual division on
the left between the moderates and the
radicals.
And that's just not played itself out
and I think you can actually see that
happening by the proclivity of the
radical leftists to devour themselves.
Right?
So which happens on a very regular
basis,
or perhaps you can see it in the
proclivity of the radical left,
is to go after the moderates.
When the moderates criticize the
radicals,
whatever.
So there's two clumps to political
correctness.
Both of them were predicted by trait
agreeableness,
which is one of the traits that women
score higher on than men.
It's the antithesis of aggression by the
way.
And by also by being female,
which was a real shock to us because
most of the,
so let's say females and males differ
with regards to some outcome.
You try to figure out why that is.
It might be just because they're female.
There's all sorts of things associated
with being female or male that are like
second order complications.
What we found almost invariably with the
personality literatures,
if you look at differences between men
and women and then you control for
personality,
the differences go away.
So they're not differences between men
and women per se.
There are differences between
personality,
but with political correctness,
we found ineffective,
effective agreeableness,
which was a pure personality affect.
Aaron didn't effective of being female.
So we also found a pronounced effect of
having taken at least one seminar that
was politically correct in its
orientation,
so that had a walloping effect.
So there does seem to be something about
political according to that research,
which,
you know,
it's all right,
try to rely on better research,
but none has been done.
So that's the best that I got in.
And the woman who did this research is
very,
very smart and the study was well done.
So I think it's credible.
So I.
One of the things that's interesting to
me about that is that it does tie into
the Freud,
the and nightmare of devouring mother
essentially,
which was Freud's,
I think signal contribution to
psychopathology.
You know,
for most,
most of Freud's clients were people who
were struggling to get out of the
clutches of their family.
Right.
And part of that is human beings are
very dependent,
right?
Because,
well,
because we have this incredibly long
period of development.
Thirty years maybe,
but certainly 18 years,
and so it's hard to struggle up from
infancy,
mature and leave as an independent
creature and lots of people,
you see this in,
if you're a clinician,
you see this all the time.
People are so tangled up in their
families that they can't get away from
them and that's the typical situation
that Freud described.
So,
so,
uh,
so brilliantly and young also elaborated
on it.
A lot of that's a consequence of hyper
dependence,
right?
It's,
it's the danger of over protection.
Now there's a rule if you're dealing
with elderly people,
say in an elder care institution,
and the rule is something like,
don't do anything for your charges that
they can do themselves.
It's kind of a harsh rule,
you know,
if you see someone struggling with their
buttons,
maybe they're three years old,
you want to rush over and help.
It's like,
well,
maybe you don't because they need to
learn how to do up there damn buttons or
if there are 85,
they need to maintain their independence
as much as possible without your
compassion.
Stealing it from them.
Okay,
well we could hypothesize that there
would be no pathobiology as a
consequence of the female rise to
political power,
but given that females are human beings
too,
and we're pretty much rife with
pathology,
the probability that there'll be a
downside is like there is two male
participation which would be more
aggressive and hyper and hyper
competent,
aggressiveness and hypercompetition.
The probability that there would be a
downside is extraordinarily high.
Well why wouldn't it be a downside
associated with hyper protectiveness?
It's exactly what you'd expect and then
what you see playing out in the
political as far as I'm as far as I can
tell,
and maybe I'm wrong,
is wherever there's a negative quality,
there's an oppressor,
oppression narrative,
and so anyone who's stacks up at the
bottom of a hierarchy is a victim slash
infant and anyone at the top is an
oppressor slash predator and I think
confusing the hierarchical structure,
especially when it's based on competence
and western structures of hierarchy are
based in large part,
although not entirely on competence.
Confusing that with a Predator infant or
oppressor oppression relationship is a
very bad idea.
Now,
having said that,
it's obvious that every social structure
has a tyrannical element,
like nobody in their right mind is going
to say,
well,
our cultural structures are a hundred
percent fair and just obviously they're
not in every single person in this room
and some far more than others have been
brutalized by the social structure,
which takes you around the neck,
shakes the hell out of you and says you
better be like everyone else or else.
Right?
That's the tyrannical aspect of the
social structure.
So you have to be naive not to think
that there's some old pressure
oppressor,
oppression dynamic in a social
structure,
but to make that the only,
the only element of the discussion is
extraordinarily dangerous.
I mean,
one of the things that looking at
terrible things has done for me is make
me a very grateful person.
Like when I walk out on the street and I
see that people aren't at each other's
throats.
I really think that that's a miracle.
Like I was just in Manhattan for a week.
You know,
if your eyes are open,
that place is an absolute miracle.
I mean,
there's way too many people there.
7 million people come in to date,
right?
It's,
it's,
there's way too many people.
They're just stacked on top of each
other.
These all these massive skyscrapers and
they all stand up there.
They all,
all standing up,
all the traffic lights work,
all the electricity works.
The buildings aren't blowing up one
after another because of natural gas
leaks.
They just don't blow up and people
aren't like beating each other to death
with clubs in the street.
It's like,
so when I go outside in New York,
I think,
my God,
how did we manage this?
Because I'm a hub.
See,
and by nature,
you know,
I think,
and it's not like I'm entirely
pessimistic,
but I think that you're naive if you
don't think that the natural state of
human beings is one of brutality,
all you have to do is look at history
and you'll be convinced of that very
rapidly.
And so the fact that,
look at us,
we can all sit in here.
We don't know who.
We don't know each other and we're
having a contentious political
discussion and like nothing terrible is
happening and if you don't see that as a
miracle,
then you're way to protect for your own
good.
So well.
So back to the back to the
agreeableness.
There are tyrannies of care.
The psychoanalysts said the good mother
fails.
And what that means is that when your
kid is three years old,
two years old and stumbling around
making mistakes,
you back the hell off and you let them
make mistakes and you don't view the
world as the infant in Predator and you
don't project that onto the political
system because it's not a good idea.
Especially if those who,
especially for those who you
misdiagnosis as predators.
Okay,
so now we're going to open it up for q
and a.
all right?
Uh,
so the,
the idea that I've put thought into this
as perhaps a optimistic one,
but as you might imagine,
you've been a topic of conversation on
this campus a lot in the past week or
so.
Certainly among a lot of us who discuss
politics.
And one of the things that sort of
united people who liked and disliked a
lot of your ideas is that we appreciate
your defensive free speech and we
appreciate you coming here to talk about
it with us.
Uh,
but one of the things I thought was
really interesting is professor van
Vandyke addressed the distinction
between you and Jonathan Heit and you
mentioned this as sort of a
temperamental one.
And I think,
I'm sure that's true to some extent,
but I,
I noticed you've made a lot of more sort
of substantively inflammatory claims.
Like in the course of this lecture you
called the peep the authors of facebook
posts demons into totality Tarion's,
uh,
in past events you've called them things
like a neo Marxist Cultural Marxists
you've called them.
Uh,
I believe a fifth column that is
committing treason against the west.
And it seems to me this is more than
temperamental.
This is a substantive difference and
difference.
And another thing you've done is that
unlike height,
you have a more sort of comprehensive
political program.
You've talked a lot in defensive,
traditional hierarchies,
both gender of class.
So on the lymphatically not race,
uh,
and so I haven't talked about defensive,
traditional hierarchies in terms of
gender and class.
That's not true.
Well,
you've talked about hierarchies in
society.
You've talked about that.
That's true.
I haven't done.
I haven't justified them on the basis of
gender and class.
You,
you whatever talked not okay.
That's an important distinction.
But you defend hierarchies in society in
a way that you talk a lot about the
predo distribution.
Yes.
That doesn't mean I defend it.
Well,
okay.
You know,
not well.
Okay.
Yes.
Well,
I mean I think you talked about loving
that something exists is not the same as
defending it.
How in the world people attack it.
Right?
So you don't.
People attack it apparently attack the
hierarchies of society's inherently
unjust.
Right?
Well,
they are,
they're unjust.
They're also useful.
Okay.
So you said they're useful some level.
We'll just look at it this way.
You obviously think that it's worthwhile
to stand up and ask a question.
Yes.
So you think that standing up and asking
a question is better than not standing
up and asking your question?
Yes.
Okay.
That's a hierarchy of values.
Yes.
Okay.
Without the hierarchy of values,
you couldn't act,
of course.
No,
no,
not course.
It's partly why I'm defending the
hierarchy hierarchy hierarchy,
right?
What's that?
There is a hierarchy in society right
now.
There's multiple.
There are multiple hierarchies in
society.
Right,
and you say that they are based in you.
You invoke the lobster,
right,
that they are based in in nature.
I said that they were inevitable,
that they were inevitable.
Some people are good,
but my point is that this is Jenna.
Do you have a broader point then free
speech.
This is one of the things you talk
about.
Yes,
yes.
Okay.
Whereas I think there's some other
activist who focus on more exclusive,
not an activist.
There's some other individuals who
engage in public political speech.
Okay.
Yeah.
Who.
Who focus more exclusively on free
speech.
Whereas you have other goals in mind,
but one of the things that you're more
inflammatory language and it's fair,
it's a subsidy of disagreement,
has done,
I think is it's politicized.
This free speaks to an extent that
someone like height hasn't.
I've noticed that when someone hears the
term free speech now they associate it
with a specific set of thinkers often is
viewed as on the extreme,
right,
and I think,
I think arguably that's the problem of
all factions in society because free
speech should be a universal value.
Polls certainly suggests that it's
coming under increasing threat from both
sides,
but I suppose the heart of my question
in addition to of course these other
observations is that do you believe free
speech is your primary end or do you
believe these other points you're making
are important because I've heard you a
bunch of times defend free speech sort
of contextually like you've complained
about some of the laws in Canada that
you dislike,
that they institutionalized false facts
into the law,
but it seems to me that in absolute is
defensive free speech makes no
preferences to true or false.
The point is that something you are
being forced to say something.
It wouldn't be as bad as if you were
forced to say something.
That is true because the point of free
speech is that you can say whatever you
want,
right?
No,
the point of free speech is so that you
can think your way through life without
running toll position a versus perfect
position b is just as bad.
Right?
Even if one is true and the other is
not.
Okay.
Well there was a bunch of questions.
Yes,
good job by the way.
We'll actually wait.
Can I just ask one additional agenda
which is
I think the politicization of free
speech is by far the biggest threat to
free speech because this has always been
a radical.
Leftists are the biggest
disagreement.
Professor Greely alluded to in previous
questions.
The subsidies,
threats to free speech in much of the
world in Europe.
Certainly I think in the United States
as well from the government have come
from the radical right and I think it's
fair to say that on the specific narrow
subset of certain departments on liberal
arts colleges,
it's fair to say threat comes from the
left though its scope is in dispute,
but my question is you think that the
way you talk about free speech,
the way you link it to specific issues,
the way you use inflammatory language
and the way you seem to make it,
you seem to defend a specific set of
free speech.
There's certainly plenty of instances of
free speech attacked on the other side
that you don't mention as.
Do you think you risked politicizing
this because it seems to me that was
okay and not think that's a far greater
threat because for example,
the NRA,
the NRA is a group in the United States,
the defense guns rights.
Right.
Hold it.
Yes.
We need a question.
Okay.
Like I said,
you're doing fine.
It's just too much.
Like I can't keep.
I think that your behavior risk
politicizing it and do you think that
polarization is justified?
Okay.
I think my behavior risks,
politicizing it,
yes,
I would rather it not be politicized and
I'm doing what I can to manage that risk
however it's become political in my
country because the government
implemented compelled speech
legislation,
so I wasn't complaining about that
before.
It became political now and there are,
there is a time,
even when you're detached in some sense
from the political realm that you can't
be detached anymore.
Well,
I'm not happy with the fact that this
has become politicized.
You could say that I haven't done a
stellar job in ensuring in every
possible manner that this is remained
neutrally a political,
probably true,
you know,
but I'm not particularly unhappy with
the way things have gone so far.
So.
And I'm not happy with the radical left.
And so if they're irritated at me so
much,
the better as far as I'm concerned.
So have I conducted myself perfectly,
it's like a undoubtedly know.
So I'm,
I'm,
I've got more than my fair share of
faults and a temper is one of them.
But,
um,
I'm muddling through.
Hm,
alright.
I'm almost hesitant to ask you a
question now.
Uh,
but,
um,
so,
uh,
one thing I was wondering about was a
lot of people I think would argue that
I'm kind of the values of Western
civilization,
uh,
free speech,
the right of the individual,
a separation between church and state
have developed through not so much a in
continuous with the Judeo Christian
morality,
but almost in their overthrow through
such things as the enlightenment,
the scientific revolution and how these
values,
uh,
would never have come out of just
simply,
uh,
the,
the continuous of the Middle Ages and
that you did Christian morality.
But my understanding of your view would
be that those values are inherent in the
Judeo Christian morality.
And I'm just wondering how you think,
uh,
yeah,
just what is the value of Jacobs from
around in my own world?
Yeah,
it's a great question.
Um,
they're not rational values.
There are deeper than values.
I mean,
it was a surprise to me going back into
the past,
let's say,
to see how deep these values were.
But I would say that
not only are they part of the Judeo
Christian story,
let's say,
but that they're grounded in phenomena
that are even deeper than that.
Now there's been a fair bit of
investigation into the emergence of
fairplay,
let's say among animals rats or
primates,
wolves and so forth.
There's an ethos that emerges
behaviorally and is then perhaps woven
into narrative and then codify that
seems to be
isomorphic across these different levels
and I think it's been well articulated
in the narrative sense in the Judeo
Christian Corpus of stories and that
it's out of that,
that our legal systems and institutions
of rights have emerged.
People make the case that that was
fundamentally and enlightenment issue
and it was certainly the case that the
rational clarity that came along with
the enlightenment increased the degree
to which that was articulated and
transformed into law.
But I think to attribute it to that is a
great mistake.
I think it's.
I think the timespan view is way too
narrow.
That's 500 years ago.
I'm a biologically minded guy.
It's like 500 years.
That's nothing.
Five thousand years.
Well,
that's starting to register 50,000
years.
It's worthy of note 6 million years now
you're getting somewhere.
There's the ethic that we're discussing
is way deeper than something conjured up
in like 1500 by some northern Italians.
So it's an articulation of a
substructure that's much deeper than the
articulation itself.
That's what it looks like to me now.
I think there's room for intelligent
debate about that,
but I've looked at the enlightenment
thinkers and at the deeper at,
at people who I regard as deeper and I
think the deeper guys,
Nietzsche,
Dostoevsky young in particular social
units to some degree they've got it
right.
So I don't think it's,
I don't think that our rights are an
enlightenment project there
instantiation into codified law that's
more part and parcel of the
enlightenment that,
that would be particularly manifest in a
place like the United States,
you know?
So
yeah.
If I can just ask a related question is,
you mentioned each a and uh,
because from what I understand,
if you're working,
you just seem to draw from him a lot.
And again,
you said you agree with him.
So I just,
you know what he thinks a lot of things.
Yeah.
So I guess I'm wondering where you
think,
because I'm imagining you imagine he
went wrong in his interpretation of the
Christian morality and how he believes
and how he believes that's kind of a
pernicious
soy based morality.
So what do you,
what exactly do you think?
Because you agree with a lot of other
things,
Christian morality,
he created critique Christian Dogma and
and structures that's not exactly the
same thing.
So you would agree with him then?
Alright,
well,
like I said,
he's a complicated guy,
but I think the slave morality idea,
the idea that the oppressed or somehow a
virtuous,
which I don't think is a central
Christian idea by the way.
It was something that he criticized as
part and parcel of what was constructed
and,
and concretized in,
in an institutional Christianity and
neat.
You also,
and this is a deeper critique,
I think nature really criticized
institutional Christianity,
particularly the Protestant and Catholic
form.
So I would say for insufficient
attention paid to the imitation of
Christ and too much attention paid to
the idea that the work of redemption had
already been done,
which is something that also divides the
Orthodox Christian types from the
Protestants and the Catholics because
the orthodox types tend to tilt more
towards the moral demand that you
imitate Christ in your own life.
And so Nietzsche is a very.
You can't sum up very easily and I found
him extraordinarily useful in training
me how to think,
to say,
to say that you agree with him,
I don't think that you can say with
someone like nature that you agree with
him because you know nature had.
This is one thing that needs said that I
really got a kick out of because it was
the.
It's the most most arrogant statement
I've ever heard anyone make.
He said,
I can write in a sentence what it takes
other people,
a book to relate.
And then he said,
now what other people can't even relate
in a book.
And that's exactly right.
Like if you read beyond good and evil,
for example,
which is mostly aphorisms.
So because he was a very sick man and he
couldn't write for long periods of time,
so he would think for long periods of
time and then write down a little bomb
and beyond,
good and evil is just sequential pieces
of dynamite and he wasn't trying to be
systematic precisely and so that's why
it's not so easy to agree or disagree
with nature,
but you can sure let the bombs go off in
your brain if you read what he has to
say and he.
He was an interesting critic of
Christianity because you know if you're
all warped and bent and someone comes
along and tells you how your warped in
bent in a manner that might enable you
to straighten up,
it's not obvious that they're.
That you're their enemy,
that they,
they're your enemy and I think that's
the right way to read nature with
regards to Christianity.
So he there was plenty of wrought and
that was part of what was causing,
let's say,
the death of God.
Now it obvious at all that nature was
antithetically opposed to the founding
ideas.
In fact,
there's many places where he writes that
indicate quite the contrary,
so
thank you.
Okay,
so we're going to go to Alex and then
say it.
It's going to distribute the microphone.
Thank you for being here.
I really appreciate it.
Um,
so I was watching a few of your
interviews in preparation for this and I
heard you speak about religion quite a
bit and if you look up what religion
means in the webster dictionary,
you get something like a system of faith
centered on a supernatural being or
beings or something like that.
But I've heard you use religion to
describe things like punk rockers,
for example.
That's a religious experience.
So my first question would be how do you
define what is considered religious?
And then sort of as a followup to that,
if say Sam Harris,
act out,
what's that?
Religious is what you act out.
Anything you act out,
everything you act out is,
is predicated on your implicit axioms.
And the system of implicit axioms that
you hold as primary is your religious
belief system.
It doesn't matter whether you're an
atheist or not,
that's just surface,
that's just surface noise.
So it has nothing to do with divinity or
natural or it doesn't necessarily have
to do with those.
No,
it probably necessarily has to do with
it too,
but it doesn't necessarily have anything
to do with your voluntarily articulated
statements about whether or not you
believe in something like a transcendent
deity.
So mean.
What you act out is much more what you
are then,
what you say about yourself and what the
hell do you know about what you believe
anyways,
you're complicated math.
Their question.
Well seriously,
people are complicated.
You know,
like we're,
we don't,
we're not transparent to ourselves at
all.
That's why we,
that's why we have to go to university
and study psychology.
It's like,
you know,
we're,
we're not exactly black boxes,
but we are the most complicated things
there are.
Right.
And we can't even program our VCR
clocks.
So it's like how the hell can we propose
to understand ourselves and you know I'm
existentially oriented,
which is to say that I think that what
you hold to be true is best determined
as an as a consequence of an analysis of
your actions rather than as a
consequence of an analysis of what you
purport to believe.
Now in order to act,
you can't act without a hierarchy of
value,
which I tortured the other poor
questionnaire about.
You can't act without a hierarchy of
values because you can't act unless you
think one thing is better than another
because why?
Why would you act otherwise?
So that means that you're embedded
within a hierarchy of values,
whether you know it or not,
or maybe multiple fragmentary and
competing hierarchies of value,
which is all the worst for you by the
way,
because it just makes you very confused.
That hierarchy of values has an
axiomatic.
It's based on axioms and the probability
that you understand them is very low
because generally people don't
understand their axioms,
but that axiomatic system is essentially
your religious system and there's.
There's no way out of that.
As far as I can tell,
and you can say,
well,
it isn't predicated on conscious belief
in a transcendent deity.
It's like,
okay,
have it your way,
but you know,
most people in this room act out a Judeo
Christian ethic and not only do they act
it out if they're treated in a manner
that's not commensurate with that ethic,
they get very,
very,
very annoyed.
So for example,
if I failed to treat you as if you're an
embodiment of a divine fragment,
let's say that's characterized by the
ability to the ability to make free
choice and to determine your own destiny
in some sense,
or if I fail to treat you as if you're a
valued member,
valued,
contributing member of the polity as a
sovereign individual,
then you'll find that very offensive and
become angry.
It's like,
okay,
then that's what you believe.
Well,
if I ask you,
if you believe any of that,
well that's a whole different story.
You might give me some radical leftist
nonsense,
but that doesn't translate from what
you've.
That doesn't take away from the
fundamentals of your auction
as one final thing.
So when you say Sam Harris argue about
religion,
you're arguing about fundamentally
different things.
It sounds like his conception of what is
religious is very different from yours.
Yeah.
Well he tends to think of religious
religious thought the same way that a
smart 13 year old atheist thinks about a
fundamentalist Christian.
It's like,
yeah,
okay.
That just,
you're just not getting to the heart of
the matter.
You know,
and I just finished reading all of Sam's
books in the last couple of weeks and as
far as I'm concerned,
he doesn't ever get to the bottom of the
issue.
It doesn't address the fundamental
thinkers.
There are some profound thinkers,
Dostoevsky's one toll story Nicha young.
It's like they're completely absent
from.
And the same with Dawkins,
completely absent.
All that conceptualization is completely
absent from their Corpus of works.
They don't even have an understanding
for the psychological utility of
religion.
And it's a big problem.
You know,
you,
you don't get to be an atheist when the
people you attack or fundamental like,
like naive fundamentalists.
And I have some sympathy for the naive
fundamentalists,
just like what they're basically saying
is something like this,
look,
we have an ethos that's valuable.
You scientists types are casually
dismantling it.
What the hell are we supposed to do?
What?
The fundamentalists don't know what to
do about that.
So they say,
well,
creationism is science.
It's like,
well no it's not.
But that doesn't mean that they don't
have a point there.
Point,
is there something valuable here?
It's like,
don't break it casually.
What are you gonna?
Replace it with the new atheists.
Swiss wish that everybody becomes
rational.
It's like,
yeah,
sure that's going to happen.
Thank you.
Thank you Dr Peterson.
I'm A.
I'm a student of the religious studies
and and currently I'm writing an honors
thesis on religious imagery in an
Indonesian literary genre.
There's a poet,
philosopher who said the following,
which I think you like,
who by the way was a huge fan of goiter.
Hey,
you said that in addressing God,
he says he calls him the hidden reality
and he asks that hidden reality to
reveal itself,
but using the robe of metro for because
he thinks that metaphor is the only way.
I think stories are the only way that
human beings can comprehend,
you know,
the,
the hidden reality.
I know you've written a lot of you,
you speak a lot about,
uh,
about real stories.
I just wanted to ask you,
although it may be a very broad
question,
what is the place of the religious in
stories and uh,
you're religious is something like the
grammatical structure of stories I give
you go down and you look at what makes a
story a story that's religious.
Yeah.
It's not a story otherwise like a story
as a particular sort of thing.
Like in its simplest sense,
the story is an account of how to get
from point a to point b.
it's like a map,
but there's a value structure inherent
in that obviously because otherwise you
wouldn't go from point a to point b.
So just to make the map means to adopt a
value structure.
But there,
but the story is actually more
complicated than that because as you
move from point a to point b,
processes of radical transformation are
often necessary and the deep stories
about the processes of radical
transformation that occur as you move
from point a to b are basically they're
indistinguishable from religious
stories.
Now the reason they I think the reason
they they tend to become religious,
let's say,
is because it has something to do with
the gap between the finite and
comprehensible and the infinite and
uncomprehensible.
It's like we live in the finite and
comprehensible,
but we're surrounded by the infinite and
incomprehensible and there has to be a
border between those.
Have some like a mediating border.
That's poetry and art.
That's narrative,
that's religion and it's that.
It's that strange metaphorical reality.
Let's say that's not factual and it's
not comprehensible,
but that's not infinitely
incomprehensible either.
It's a bridge between the two.
So and as you move closer to the
infinite and incomprehensible across
that bridge,
you get farther and farther away from
what you understand,
right?
But how could it be otherwise given that
your finite,
you are a finite being surrounded by
infinite,
it's infinite in incomprehensible.
And that was his critique of district
rationalist and they can't do that.
It's hard for them to,
to make this a two.
That's what poets come in.
And that's exactly.
Well,
this is what I learned
a lot of this from young because young
is his idea was that rationality is
embedded in a dream,
like there's the infinite unknowable.
And then there's the dream.
And then inside the dream is the
rational domain.
And I,
I believe that to be the case.
Why else would we dream?
We have to dream.
If we don't dream,
we would go insane.
It doesn't take very long.
And so there's,
there's an element of poetic
conceptualization that grounds us and it
has to be taken seriously.
You know,
the,
the rational critics of dreams think
about them as random neuroactivity.
It's like there's nothing wrong.
When you look at a TV screen that's not
on a channel that's random.
When you dream something complex and
sophisticated,
that's not random.
So yeah,
so the metaphor surrounds us,
let's say,
and we can critique it rationally and we
can undermine it,
but there's real danger in that.
So.
Sure.
Take one question from here,
then take one on the other end.
We have a right side of the loom bias.
Hi Professor.
Yeah,
thanks you for a dark and I explained
out to from you,
um,
what's your view of institutional racism
visit a thing or is it some other lefty
radical leftist agenda?
Say,
I didn't quite get to the first.
What was your view of institutional
racism?
More systematic racism as some people
may call it a system.
Yeah,
yeah,
yes,
yes.
Is it a,
is it a thing?
It's an actual thing
that his mother had agenda that you
might attribute to radical leftists.
It's a multivariate problem,
right?
Like no society is without its biases
and prejudices and some of them get
built into the systems themselves.
And so when you look at unequal outcomes
and you're trying to discover why those
unequal outcomes exist,
if you have any sense,
then you do a multivariate analysis and
you put in prejudice and discrimination
as one of the factors,
one of
the factors,
one of many,
many factors and what the problem with
the radical leftist is that they take
the fact that societal structures are
tyrannical to some degree and arbitrary,
which of course they are because they're
imperfect and then they obliterate the
rest of the complexity with that claim.
So there's lots of reasons for
inequality,
systemic biases,
one of the two,
what did.
It's an open question to what degree
systemic bias plays in,
in the inequality problem,
let's say,
but it's something that we could
hypothetically address with a certain
degree of detachment and intelligence.
So no system is perfect,
not and certainly not all
reasonable reasonable answer.
That stuff's yes.
All right.
So I think it's safe to say you're a
fervent of postmodernism and there are
times where I don't think you quite give
it a fair shake and I'm no fan of,
you know,
a good amount of the literature or the
theory,
but if you could point to one or two of
the French theorists and some of their
pieces,
what are,
whether it's their literature,
their theory,
um,
or you could point to that's called for
this sort of cultural rot that you
charge postmodernism with causing,
who would it be,
what would it be?
I would say for Colon,
well,
if I could understand it,
but I think he is understanding
so I can't blame him.
So,
um,
and I've done my best to read and I
think the reason I can't read it is
because it doesn't make any sense.
So because I've read some very difficult
things and I could understand them.
So,
um,
for coal I think is a tin part genius.
I read Madison's civilization for
example.
It just seems to me to be self evident.
Psychiatric diagnostic categories are in
part social constructions.
It's like great.
We've known that since late 1960,
you know,
it's just not that big a revelation and
Dera Dot,
well,
he's a trickster,
you know,
in his critique of the West as logo
centric is dead on point.
Male dominated.
That's his theory and logo centric.
While he thinks that's a problem.
Well I don't think it's a problem.
So,
and I think as well it isn't even that,
and I understand the postmodernist
viewpoint,
like look,
it is the case that a finite set of
entities is subject to an infinite
number of interpretations.
Okay.
That's postmodernism in a nutshell.
The Ai guys figured that out and like
from 1960 to 1992,
it took them that long to wade through
that fundamental technical problem,
a real problem.
The problem of perception,
for example,
it's been very hard to solve the ai
problem of perception because there are
a lot of ways to look at the world.
Like the objects aren't just there in
any simple sense.
So,
okay,
there's an infinite number of
interpretations.
No problem.
There's not an infinite number of viable
interpretations.
Okay,
that's a big problem.
Okay.
And a little bit of thinking through
that would have gone a long ways for the
postmodernist.
So that's,
that's number one.
And then what's the other one?
Oh yes they did.
Then the other problem is,
okay,
there's an infinite number of
interpretations.
We won't make anyone canonical.
All right,
well then how the hell are you going to
act?
Because you have to make a value system
canonical if you're going to act.
Oh well we didn't solve that problem.
How about we just slipped Marxism and
underneath the carpet and not noticed
the problem.
Then that gives us something to do.
Like people come out and criticize me
and say,
Dr Peterson doesn't understand that
postmodernism and Marxism are
incommensurate.
It's like,
yeah,
actually I do understand that.
But the postmodern neo Marxists don't
seem to understand that.
So how can you be a postmodernist marks
Marxist at the same time?
Well,
the answer to that is actually to be
found in the historical data.
The postmodernist types like Fuco and
Derrida were Marxists before they became
postmodernists.
And the postmodern overlay on the
Marxism was,
as far as I can tell,
mostly a cover story for going about the
same old murderous idiocy under a new
guys.
So
you think it's possible that there are.
I'm sorry that there are lenses.
I'm like postmodern lenses that we can
view culture from under that can at
times be more powerful and useful than
than other lenses.
Like for example,
the idea of the simulator.
Tremendous success of phases of the
image.
I'm Joan Didion.
You could at least think,
and I mean you can't throw all the
postmodernists into the same jug,
you know,
but I would say it's still daredevils
who cove had the most pernicious
effects.
Okay.
So you would charge
well the.
Well the problem is they didn't deal
with it seriously.
It's like you can't just say no Meta
narrative.
It's like,
okay,
how are we going to unite ourselves
there?
Okay,
we're going to use multiculturalism.
Oh,
that's really worked to produce a
peaceful world,
hasn't it?
So you need a uniting narrative.
We have.
If we weren't,
didn't have a uniting narrative,
we wouldn't all be sitting peacefully in
this room.
It's the uniting narrative that governs
our behavior in this room and look,
here we are all peaceful.
It's like they're not dealing with the
fundamental issues and to slip Marxism
back in as a backdoor route to having
something to do with your life is
intellectually,
intellectually and morally
reprehensible.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yep.
C,
take one.
How are you sir?
My name is Steve.
I just wanted to ask you about this
experience that I had after watching one
of your lectures that really profoundly
impacted me and I was,
I was wondering if you could kind of
help me out with understanding this
after watching your lecture on young and
just talking about his life.
Uh,
you started talking about the lion king
and kind of connecting with the intro
scene was in the lion king and,
and the,
the idea of archetypes.
And when I started understanding what
you were saying,
I had this unbelievable feeling in my
stomach and my whole body is just his
smile like this,
like this very intense feeling.
So warning,
never to read you.
I have,
I started with ion.
So that's not a good idea.
So
it was just as powerful feeling and I,
I got so emotional,
you know,
and ask thinking about how to articulate
this question to you a few minutes ago.
I was just getting so emotional.
It was,
it was a,
it just seems like,
you know,
it scared the hell out of me,
that feeling.
But it was also a really meaningful,
so valuable,
amazing feeling and I thought,
you know,
it's Kinda like what maybe what God is
or,
you know.
Yeah,
it was just so,
and I usually get that feeling to have
have after listening to it like a band,
like the Cro mags of black flag,
arunos hardcore bands like that.
Music is so important to me like that.
And,
and um,
it's levels of reality that is stacking
on top of it.
And it just a question that just made me
so emotional too is like,
what could my life be,
you know?
And that was something that I,
I just found myself asking myself,
you know,
just what.
And I just,
I wonder if you could give me some,
some extra stuff on that without really
was,
you know.
Yeah.
Well,
you've gotTa,
you've gotta be very careful when
you're,
when you're doing something like reading
young because he'll reorganize your
cognitive structures and that's there's
deaths and rebirths that go along with
that.
You know there's what you're trying to
do in part is to,
in a sense,
as you're trying to bring what you do
and how you imagine yourself and how you
articulate yourself into alignment.
So those three things are the same.
It's very hard because there's more to
you in your auction than there is in
your articulation and there's more to
your imagination and so partly what
you're.
What you're experiencing is an expanded
sense of self and possibility and you
might think,
well,
that's a wonderful thing,
but it's a.
it's also a very daunting thing and it.
It can be a very dangerous thing.
When I was dealing with all of this
material,
when I was writing my first book,
I had to abandoned a lot of the things
that I was doing that were bad habits
because it was so stressful to move
through these systems of ideas that I
couldn't afford any additional mental
energy being wasted.
Things I was
doing that wasn't,
that weren't together.
So
you got to a prolonged debate,
uh,
on twitter with a Bot,
a Bot,
and then again on March.
Yeah,
it was a lot.
So that wasn't very break,
wasn't no.
Uh,
and then again on,
uh,
on March ninth actually with Noam
Chomsky,
a animatronic people bought.
And so,
uh,
I want to ask you as like the leading
old,
so,
um,
yeah.
So,
uh,
how,
how important do you think it is to
like,
debate these intellectuals and do you
think that you are,
you want.
Oh God,
I always hesitate,
hesitate to claim victory.
Like to,
to escape without abject defeat is a
pretty good,
pretty good ambition.
So,
um,
and plus I think it's rather improbable
that I would win a debate with a Bot.
Right?
So some people thought it was pretty
close.
Twitter is a weird platform,
you know,
it's,
it's complicated,
complicated
platform and I've,
I've modified my approach to twitter in
the last month and half I would say.
I've been trying to selectively retweet
information.
I pulled a bunch of people and asked
them if they knew of credible twitter
sources that we're producing
valid good news.
And I found a bunch of sites that were
doing that and then winnow them down.
I really like human progress.org,
which has done a lovely job of
detailing.
Well they had a,
they had a great tweet the other day I
really loved.
It was a mock up of a New York Times
cover and it said 127,000 people lifted
out of abject poverty today,
you know,
in like large type.
And then the tweet was we could have run
this every single day for the last 20
years.
It's like,
you know,
because some of you know,
but perhaps some of you don't that
between the year 2000 and 2012 and this
hasn't stopped yet.
The number of people in abject poverty
in the world fell by my half,
right?
It was the most rapid period of economic
development ever in the history of the
world.
And there's lots of things like that
happening.
There's several hundred thousand people
a day being hooked to the power grid,
which is a big deal for those of you.
Those of you who have power might also
appreciate that.
Um,
infant mortality has been plummeting.
You know,
we're going to plateau in terms of
population at about $9 billion and it's
going to level off and decline pretty
rapidly after that.
People are getting access to fresh water
in record numbers like there,
there's so many good things happening
that it's not even funny and,
uh,
that we,
that are real cause for celebration.
And so I've been trying to select trying
to tilt what I've been distributed more
in that direction.
And I've also put a buffer between me
and my use of twitter.
So,
because it,
it does,
it does reward an impulsivity that isn't
always,
um,
let's say my impulsivity that it isn't
always in anyone's best interest.
I made an agreement with my son too,
because he's been watching what I have,
lots of people watching what I'm doing
and trying to keep me under some degree
of control,
let's say,
and his comment was that if I was going
to,
if it was serious enough to engage in
twitter,
combat about it was serious enough to
write a blog post about and so I've kind
of made this rule which is I'm not going
to comment on anything on twitter and
that sort of manner unless I feel that
writing about it at some length is
justifiable.
And so I started doing that this week.
I wrote three blog posts and that seems
to have gone pretty well,
so I hope that answered your question.
Yep.
Kind of go on a different topic.
I have a personality psychology
question.
Okay.
So when I did the understand myself
quiz,
I was very surprised to find out that I
was on the bottom two percentile for
conscientiousness,
which I thought was an openness.
Yes,
you're an entrepreneurial type.
I'm going to need to partner with
someone whose disciplines
that's exactly.
See,
there seems to be a real tension between
openness and especially orderliness was
open.
People while they think laterally and
they blow boxes apart and they tend to
make a mess when you're transforming
things and they're all over the place
and they have to be because otherwise
they wouldn't be open,
but it's hard to do that and also be
orderly and conscientious and so and and
corporation suffer from this tension all
the time.
Right?
Because they're started by open people,
but when they get going and get
algorithmize they're run by
conscientious people,
but then the conscientious people can
only go down one track and if the
environment transforms,
the whole company disappears.
So I would say you take a look at the
conscientiousness score.
You see if you can figure out how to
discipline yourself a bit more and see
if you can figure out how to schedule
your time.
Not like a prison but like a,
like a structured set of opportunities.
And then you understand that in order to
be successful in life,
likely in the medium to long run,
you're going to have to find someone
could be someone close to you,
could be be business partners or
whatever that fill in that missing
conscientiousness gap.
So I guess the part B was,
uh,
my boyfriend,
we've been together for a very long time
and we're not that old,
uh,
is also very high in neuroticism.
And I feel that's where like our
conflict comes.
And as far as longterm,
what are some things that,
you know,
lowly,
conscientious and highly neurotic.
So
we'll look into that.
I mean the simple,
I can only high levels of neuroticism
are problematic interrelationship.
It's probably why 75 percent of divorces
are initiated by women because women are
higher in neuroticism.
That meant.
And I think the reason for that is that
they have to be more sensitive to infant
distress.
And so that makes them more sensitive to
distress in general.
Now,
I don't know that for sure it's a
supposition,
but high levels of neuroticism do tend
to make a relationship volatiles and and
and to put a fair bit of negative
emotion into it and the question is
where,
what the source of the high level of
neuroticism is.
It might be purely temperamental,
but it also might be indicative of an
underlying anxiety disorder,
depression or,
or a physiological problem because they
can manifest themselves in high levels
of negative emotion and so there's
always the possibility of doing
something about that.
What I usually tell my clients who are
high in neuroticism is two simple
things.
Number one,
get up at the same time in the morning.
Okay,
because that helps stabilize your
circadian rhythms.
Number two,
eat a large meal before you stress
yourself in the morning and mostly
protein and fat based because if you're
high in neuroticism and you stress
yourself before you eat you,
you disregulate your,
your emotional reaction systems
essentially,
and you can't reregulate them until you
sleep again.
So other than that,
goodwill and understanding is about what
you've got
doing tonight.
Dr Pearson.
Pretty good question.
So on the brutal side,
I might say,
but nervous to talk in front of you
because you've got to be one of the most
formidable people that I've ever heard
of or ever listened to every scene.
So my question is,
again,
you're one of the best communicators
that I've ever listened to.
If I could be half as good at you are at
communicating as you are,
I would be set.
How can I teach myself to do that
practice?
You know,
really like,
well there's a couple of things is helps
to read a lot.
It really helps to.
Right?
So if you want to make yourself
articulate,
which is a very good idea,
then not only should you read,
but you should write down what you
think.
And if you can do that a little bit
every day,
15 minutes,
maybe you could steal 15 minutes and do
it every day.
But if you do that for 10 years,
you really straightened out.
You're thinking if you're going to speak
effectively,
you have to know way more than you're
talking about.
You know?
So if you.
This is often difficult for beginning
lectures at university because they'll
do a lecture on a topic,
but they only know as much as they're
saying in the lecture and they get kind
of stuck to their notes because of it,
but you want to know 10 times as much as
you are saying in the lecture and then
you can specify a stepping path through
it and elaborate with the other things
that you know.
But to do that you have to do a lot of
reading,
but you also have to do a lot of reading
because that's where the synthesize,
that's where the synthesizing comes.
So that's on the input side.
And then on the output side,
well there's some tricks.
Techniques let's say is like if you're
speaking in front of a group,
you are not delivering a talk to a
group.
That's not what you're doing.
The talk isn't a packaged thing that you
present to a group.
There isn't a group,
there's a bunch of individuals and you
talk to them.
So when I talked to a group,
I always talk to people one at a time
and that makes it easier too because you
know how to talk to a person.
It's like,
can you talk to a thousand people?
Well probably not because it's too
intimidating,
but there isn't a thousand people there.
There's thousand individuals and so you
just look at an individual and you say
something and you can tell if they're
engaged,
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or maybe they're asleep,
in which case you look at someone else
and they give you feedback about how
you're doing.
And so one thing is to have something to
say.
Yeah,
the next thing is pay attention to who
you're talking to because unless you're
very badly socialized and that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least
moderately.
Well,
you know,
and well,
I mean I don't know you very well but in
first,
but on first sight,
you know you're,
you're doing fine.
So the probability that if you pay
attention to the individuals that you're
talking to,
that your natural wealth of,
of social skill will manifest itself,
is extremely high,
and so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience.
That's a really bad way of thinking
about it.
You're actually engaged in a
conversation with an audience,
even if they're not talking,
they're nodding and shifting position
and you know,
looking like this or,
and you can,
you can pull that in and,
and,
and use it to govern the level at which
you're addressing the entire audience.
So
the last thing I would say as well,
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start.
And you think,
well,
I can buttress that to some degree are
there isn't anything that you can boss.
This is the whole point of a liberal
education.
There isn't anything that you can
possibly do that makes you more
competent in everything you do.
Then to learn how to communicate.
I don't care if you're going to be a
carpenter.
I mean being a carpenter by the way is
very difficult,
especially if you're a good carpenter.
But if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter,
you're like 10 times better as a carpet.
So the,
and this is something that the liberal
arts colleges,
I think,
I don't know if they've forgotten it,
but they don't do a very good job of
marketing.
It's like,
well,
what's the use of a bachelor's degree in
Bachelor of arts?
It's like,
well,
you can think,
you can write,
you can speak.
You've read something.
It's like the economic value that is
incalculable.
The people that I've watched in my life
who've been spectacularly successful
are.
They have skills.
Clearly that's a minimum precondition,
but they're also very,
very good at articulating the shells.
And so whenever they negotiate their
successful well,
that's kind of like the definition of
success in life,
right?
You negotiate and you're six.
It doesn't mean you win because if
you're a good negotiator,
if you're really good negotiator,
everybody walks away from the
negotiation derailed and so then people
line up to do things with you.
So.
And that's all.
That's all dependent on your ability to
communicate.
So practice.
Thank you very much.
Oh,
thanks.
Sorry I have.
There's a section of the book in here
that I just want to talk about here.
Confident young man.
Rule 11 of this book here.
Don't bother children when you're
skateboarding.
Well,
the small bone to pick with Lafayette
college is that my brother does get
stopped skateboarding here,
but that's not the surprise of my
questions today.
I'm really.
I have two key questions.
You said in one lecture that Alexander
Soldier nation basically memorize the
other work to bring it out and to show
the world,
but I've had professors who started to
be in ones that are very studied on
Slavic Culture and studied on the Gulag.
Tell me essentially that he was a kgb
agent.
I mean,
would you agree with that statement that
the only way that he would have been
able to get all that stuff out of their
live in there for 20 years and not die
or starve to death was from that?
What do you don't really have anything
to say about that?
I mean,
anything's possible,
but probably not that.
Probably not that KGB agent like I don't
know why anyone would tell you that.
What's your evidence for that?
It's an impossible for him to have
documented that.
That must've been a kgb agent,
like memorize all of that.
Getting out of prison
was your writing in prison and he
couldn't.
He couldn't have done anything.
You'd be amazed at what people can
remember when they have to remember.
So people remember very large volumes of
material when they're,
when that's what they have.
I get like preliterate people.
No.
All they did was remember I have a
friend who's not literate and what he
can.
I have two friends that aren't really
very literate.
One of them is really not
literate and what he can remember,
you just can't believe are modern people
don't remember much because we don't
have to.
We write it down and externalize it,
but our capacity for memory is,
is far greater than you realize the
shake from when the Greeks switch from
an oral culture to a literary culture
was very fascinating.
But my second question before I go sit
back down with,
um,
how do you feel about the influence of,
uh,
and I,
you know,
with reading Terence Mckenna and things
along these lines,
the humans of psychedelics within our
culture and how that,
and what that does to the human psyche.
I know that the guy who,
God only knows,
I don't think we understand.
We don't understand psychedelics one
bit,
so
I don't think we understand that forest,
they,
what would you play the role that
they've played in our religious and
cognitive evolution.
So we don't understand that they're an
absolute mystery.
So
play with them at your peril.
Acid.
Yeah.
Swiss,
a pretty strange place for that emerged
from.
But yeah,
reference the chairs and for random
audience members.
The sentence
in a lot of your talks,
you speak about the things that the west
you'd correct.
And I'm curious yourself being a
psychologist,
what your thoughts are on Edward Bernays
and the impact that he had on Western
society.
The,
um,
the guiding of masses are controlling
them and being able to take control in
that way.
No,
I don't know enough about them.
I'm afraid to give you an intelligent
answer.
So do you have,
do you have another question because
that's rather disappointed.
I imagine
a shared.
Um,
my other question would be that,
uh,
to my understanding that work control
and people's control is instrumental in
the idea of socialism and if these
countries that we call socialist and
communist are totalitarian states ruled
by a single party or a single man,
why do we continue referring to them as
such
as referring them to,
as,
as socialists,
as when they don't follow the main heart
of it?
Yeah.
Good or control?
It's a good question.
I don't,
I don't really know the answer to that.
It looks like,
who knows,
right.
Maybe,
maybe the,
maybe the inevitable end product of a
collectivist view point is something
like a totalitarian state.
It seems probable because most human
governments have been essentially
totalitarian states have one degree of
severity or another.
So the tribal tendency might manifest
itself in a rigid hierarchy,
but it is,
it is a perverse fact.
Right.
And you think that it's one of the
mysteries about the continual
apologetics for the radical left.
It's like,
well,
didn't China just announced that it's
president is now president for life.
So that's actually a big problem.
Well,
and despite the fact that they've moved
quite a distance in the free market
direction,
obviously that underlying totalitarian
impulse is still alive then and well and
thriving.
I mean,
and what the Chinese are doing with
electronic surveillance should make
everyone's hair stand on end.
So
yeah.
Thank you.
Hi,
Dr Peterson
to
Mike Range.
It's a pleasure to ask you a question.
I wrote it down to minimize
inarticulate.
So you,
you put a great emphasis on truth in
your work.
Uh,
so this is your writing in 12 rules for
life and above all,
don't lie.
Don't lie about anything ever lying
leads to hell.
It was the great and the small eyes of
the Nazis and communists states that
produce the deaths of tens of millions
of people.
And you've also talked about how niche
of foresaw the nihilism implicit in
European culture in the 18 hundreds,
uh,
that would likely lead to the
authoritarianism and death tolls
mentioned at the end of the previous
quote.
Uh,
and I find this interesting for the
following reason.
Uh,
so here's Nisha and the will to power
radical nihilism is the conviction of an
absolute untenable out of existence when
it comes to the highest values.
One recognizes this realization is a
consequence of the cultivation of
truthfulness.
So in other words,
a Nisha saw the,
uh,
that valuing truth to it's fullest
undercuts valuation itself.
Yeah.
He specifically within a Christian
context,
by the way,
I mean,
one of the things that,
that need you in his role as Christian
critic pointed out was that the death of
God was a consequence in his formulation
of the Christian insistence on truth.
So his,
his idea was essentially that as
Christianity elevated the truth to the
position of highest moral virtue,
and then that truth seeking spirit
develop scientific and rational
viewpoint,
that the logical consequence of that was
the turning of the spirit of truth.
On the metaphysical presumptions of
Christianity itself.
So that's the context for that.
So
I wanted to ask you is that you appear
to care deeply about meeting and the
philosophical problem of nihilism.
So I was just wondering if you could
elaborate on this tension between
nihilism and truth in light of what
you're saying and whether there's a way
in which you see your ideas as
elaborated in your latest book as a
solution to the problem of nihilism or
how they fit into the broader.
Great question.
Um,
I think,
I think really the young's work is the
answer to that question because yoga was
profoundly influenced by Freud
obviously.
And if you read the Freudian
biographers,
let's say it's easy to conceptualize
young as an acolyte of Freud,
but it's not really accurate,
I wouldn't say or it's insufficiently
accurate because Freud had a great
influence on you,
but you was also exceptionally
influenced by niching and you'll,
I think you can also view piaget in this
matter by the way,
although not directly as a consequence
of the influence of niche.
It'd be more indirect,
but young really regarded what he was
doing as an answer to niches question
and the question is something like,
well,
the inquirer inquiring western rational
mind has murdered the metaphysical
presuppositions of Western society.
Now what now niches idea was,
well,
we would have to invent our own values.
We would have to become a new type of
being,
but your response to that,
especially after World War Two was and
after encountering Freud was something
like,
well,
what makes you think we can invent our
own values?
So Neil Young's idea was to rediscover
the values of the past,
to go within.
That was his hero's journey to go within
in the landscape of the imagination and
to rekindle the archetypes.
That isn't necessarily something that
has to be done as an internal voyage,
but
that made it.
That made the process something that was
more akin to an archetypical
transformation.
So if it's the father that's dead,
then you go into the belly of the beast
to revitalize the father.
That's the pathway forward.
And that's been the pathway forward for
human beings for for as long back as we
know for tens of thousands of years.
Yeah.
Well,
I think I'm saying that right.
Some Romanian wrote me the other day and
tried to teach me how to say it.
Merchant.
I think that's right.
Eliana talked about the the death of God
as a recurring phenomena.
I mean that's what he.
That's when he realized when he did his
large scale surveys of religious belief
systems is the God dies very frequently
and then that's part of it.
That's part of what you might describe
as a developmental process.
It's very much akin to what happens to
you when your dreams die.
You know,
when you put forward a hypothesis about
mode of being that you would like to
embody.
You have a dream,
a vision and ambition,
maybe a love affair or something like
that and it collapses on you when
there's a period of death that follows
that.
You could call it psychological death,
but then there's a reconstruction of the
value system and a rebirth,
and that's.
That's the eternal human story.
It really is.
Now,
Young's contribution to niches,
body of thought,
and this is where I think also dusty
does the surpassed Mnuchin,
was that you realized that we didn't
invent our own values.
We rediscovered those values that we
always harbored within us.
Now,
that doesn't mean that that,
that they still have to be given new
form,
though you see this in an old story of
the Egyptian,
there's an old story of Horus.
No,
Cyrus and horace goes to rescue his
father.
Oh,
Cyrus,
who's basically living like a dead ghost
in the underworld.
He goes to rescue him after defeating
his evil uncle goes to rescue his dead
father,
and when he goes down into the
underworld,
he,
he has an I in his hand that seth,
the evil one,
tore from his head during their combat
and instead of putting the [inaudible]
back in his head,
he gives it to his father and then his
father can see again,
and then they both go back up to the
surface of the world and it's their
union that constitutes the spirit of the
Pharaoh.
It's an absolutely unbelievably
remarkable story because the idea is,
well,
you will be damaged in your
confrontation with life,
particularly if you confront malevolence
because the confrontation with
malevolence damages people that will
damage your vision,
but if you,
if you take that damaged part of you and
you read united with the dead spirit of
your father,
then you can revitalize that.
That will strengthen you and that will
enable you to move forward into the
future.
So like that's just exactly right and
it's one of the deepest religious
presuppositions of humanity.
You see it everywhere.
That idea,
and that's what you're doing in
university.
If you take a liberal arts course
degree,
it's like you're,
you're,
you're resurrecting your dead ancestors
so they can live again in your form,
but in conjoined union with you,
you're the vision that gives the dead
past its vitality and spirit,
and that's the purpose of being
educated.
That's a,
that's your initiation and and partly
what you do when you're initiated
properly in that regard.
As you develop a comprehensive
philosophy of good and evil,
a deep philosophy of good and evil,
evil,
and that protects you against the
confrontation with malevolence and I
know that you know,
I know that not least because one of the
things that's happened to me as a
consequence and putting all these
lectures online is that I've had many
military people write me and come and
talk to me who had posttraumatic stress
disorder and that's almost always a
consequence.
Often have them viewing themselves do
something dreadful,
but sometimes viewing that occurring as
a consequence of other people's actions
until they have a philosophy of good and
evil,
they can't recover from their
posttraumatic stress disorder and like
you,
if you're naive,
metaphysically naive,
and you come in contact with someone who
truly wants to hurt you,
the probability that that will undo you
psychologically is very,
very high.
So you have to be wise as serpents.
That's the old saying.
You have to be wise as a serpent because
otherwise you have no protection against
serpents.
Maybe we'll do two more because I'm
starting to get fuzzy minded and I've
learned to quit at that point mostly.
So we talked a bit before.
Yeah,
before you started.
Don't know exactly how to phrase this
and I think that this will be like,
I do want to like acknowledge that all
of this q and a has been amazing because
it's basically been a lecturer mixed
with reality and that's a good
combination.
Yeah,
it's a good combination and I don't
think many speakers I go to actually
know how to combine that the way you
did.
So thank you for that.
But uh,
I guess this question is a bit of a
departure from that and it's sort of
going to something more of a say I don't
think everyone can relate to because
it's in your book you say don't lie.
And I think that after living 21 short
years,
I've learned that the hard way,
but you and your life and me and my
life,
I feel like we both had a moment where
we've had to confront a self alienating
instance of nature where there is no
path forward that we really have at our
disposal and
there was a point where an unnatural
amount of growth had to come out of us.
So I just want to know where you drew
that line at your own ability to develop
as a person to where you didn't become
tunnel vision with trying to face life's
problems on your own or.
Okay.
Well we had talked just before this
second part of this q and a about my
daughter's illness and about this
gentleman's had illness in his family
too.
So that's Kinda the background of this.
Well the first part of that is like
if we were going to be pessimistically
realistic about all this,
I would say that your best bet is truth.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that's
always going to do the trick,
right?
I mean sometimes you go fight a dragon
entity to you and if the,
if you being eaten wasn't a real
possibility,
it wouldn't be a real fight.
And so you see people,
like I've seen people
in my clinical practice sometimes I had
one client in particular who was
undergoing a particularly vicious
divorce with someone who was really
seriously inclined to take him out and
would do pretty much everything at her
disposal to do so.
And I strategized with him for about
three years and we did everything like
at hyper carefully and he was a very
conscientious and diligent person and he
put into practice everything that we
discussed and strategized and he still
pretty much,
he got backed into a corner so hard that
I didn't know how to help them anymore.
So high would say however that he like.
He was a very truthful person throughout
that.
And one thing he did do was part of it
was a custody battle and he did manage,
despite his declined in consequence of
being repeatedly cornered,
I would say.
He did manage to establish what I think
was a lasting relationship with his
kids.
So he might've got enough out of what he
did to justify it,
even though the whole landscape was
pretty awful.
I think that not lying is your best bet,
but life is hard and people get run over
and it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to emerge in any obvious
sense triumphant.
But if you take the alternative path
path,
especially when you're facing severe
tribulations,
let's say,
and you complicate those with deceit,
you can be sure that whatever tragedy
that you're confronting is going to turn
into not only tragedy,
but something very much akin to hell.
And so you might be able to at least
minimize the degree of suffering even if
you can't overcome it or transcendent.
And that's something,
you know,
it's something I,
I'm always reminded in a discussion like
this of what I watched with my wife's
family were around the deathbed of her
mother.
She had
frontal temporal dementia,
which is like Alzheimer's and quite an
awful way to go.
And,
uh,
her husband,
my father in law,
really stepped up to the plate.
Like he was quite the man about town,
very extroverted partier type and quite
disagreeable.
But when his wife got sick,
man,
he was there,
it was something to watch and so he
turned what could have been absolutely
dreadful into just miserable and then
when their entire family was gathered
around her death bed,
like my wife and her sister had both
dealt with dying people before and other
sister was a pharmacist and they were
attentive to their mother and there was
no foolish catastrophes going on between
the family and they all pulled together
and so their mother died.
But what I observed was that their bonds
were strengthened as a consequence and
that they gained something from the
tightening of the remaining
relationships that was at least partial
compensation for the loss of their
mother.
And that beat the hell out of squabbling
about everything while she was dying.
Because that's a real possibility.
And people certainly do that.
So
one more,
and maybe we'll call it a night.
The one thing that has been kind of
going through my mind in this discussion
in general,
personally,
one of the most interesting aspects of
neuroscience to me is the capacity to
change the adaptive.
But I think that the issue in your talks
and you know you're already doing so
that people
can be
five points that will never be stagnant
and not to shame therapy.
They don't really understand that maybe
to the love that they should be.
Right.
And so my opinion is that that indicates
a little bit of a paragraph that was,
you know,
we are wired,
we are hardwired essentially adapt to
change.
We're able to change ourselves to
respond to the same line,
our environmental,
our brand itself,
not just our behavior,
but the actual,
the in our vision of what's actually
changing.
So you're already is that a lot of
people will become,
you know,
to this and they'll stay stagnant.
So how do you explain what aspects of
cultural phenomena or just social
discourse,
what is so powerful about that,
that it overcomes,
are predisposed conditions?
Well,
changes changes,
especially if it's the more radical than
necessary change.
The more pain that accompanies it,
like the more opportunity as well.
But,
and a lot of what we learned,
we learned painfully.
And so it's not surprising that people
shrink away from learning.
We learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently.
Everyone knows that,
like the things that really that you
really learned in life,
it's like it was no joy man and get took
you out and so the fact that people flee
from that is hardly surprising,
but it doesn't help.
That's the thing.
It just stores up the catastrophe for
later and so the better the better ideas
to eat a little poison every day so that
you don't have to overdose in a month.
It's something like that and it is the
case that I think because you don't,
you aren't forced.
First of all,
you don't learn unless you're forced to
learn.
I know there's alternatives to that.
There's the voluntary search for
knowledge and that's a fine thing and
that is an antidote to this,
but apart from that,
speaking more practically,
you tend not to learn unless you're
forced to learn and it's and what you
tend to learn by force or difficult
lessons and so people are very prone to
not to not seek that out.
It's not surprising,
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well.
You know,
you,
you.
It's because maybe it's because they're
convinced that there's some way of
forestalling the necessary learning and
there isn't any way of forestalling it.
All you do is make it worse in the
future.
You make yourself smaller and you make
the lesson harder,
and so that's why in so many religious
doctrines there's emphasis on humility.
Humility is to debase yourself.
It's to understand that you don't know
enough so that your life isn't going to
be miserable and so every chance you get
to grab something new that will help you
along your way.
You should take it as fast as you can,
but you have to have a very
tragic,
I would say,
view of reality and also harsh one
because it's not just tragedy.
It's also malevolence.
You have to understand that those are
waiting for you and that makes you
desperate enough to learn and that might
be make you desperate enough to fall out
of the radiology,
but that's.
That's a hard way of looking at the
world beats living through it though.
It's was very nice talking to you.
Thank you.